foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the fastest kid on the Block welcome
everyone this is the junior speed Chess
Championship I'm International
alongside me Michael commentator in a
crime Grandmaster Robert has Robert I'm
still recovering from all the action
from the plane and it's going to be
another day of nail biting chess
yeah we switch gears from the aim chest
rapid to the junior speed Chess
Championship but here in the JC's SEC
you know all these hungry kids what they
want the most is not just to beat their
opposition but make their way to the
speed Chess Championship
that is the big prize at the end of the
road the golden ticket to the main speed
Chess Championship and of course the
biggest talents will be buying for that
spot what is the junior SP Chess
Championship let's talk about all the
action that's coming up it is a platform
for the biggest chest talents across the
world in a grueling format to Crown the
fastest of the lot and this year it is
only for players who are 18 or under
four players were invited to the jscc
and four have qualified and of course
Robert it is fifty thousand dollars on
the line but once again the big ticket
to the main speed Chess Championship
oh yeah because in the SCC you meet the
likes of Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura but those names are safe for a
later date because here in this single
elimination bracket Tyler these are all
the names we have to talk about some
superstars in the making some Superstars
already
and that's the cool thing about Junior
speed Chess Championship we've seen
previous winners go on to graduate to
become these World elite players and we
might be seeing that in this Edition as
well the four qualified players Robert
gukesh Christopher you ranak sadwani and
Dana slazovic will be playing against uh
the four players who qualified in the
May event which is uh Ohanian pranav
samadov and Darda what are you expecting
from these matchups and the single
elimination bracket you know you
mentioned how some players were invited
others qualified I expect to not care
about any of that and the reason why is
because all the players in this field
are super strong and we're starting off
with goo cash and Ohanian of course
number 13 in the live ratings did so
well in Norway chess but oh honey does
not care he is ready to take down his
super GM opponent so kukesh he needs to
be on his toes he needs to be playing
carefully it's going to be a tough match
super strong hungry for the winds and
super duper talented this is the match
that we will be starting with with gkesh
who just recently turned 17 and on his
17th birthday beat a certain Magnus
Carlsen in the blitz event of the Norway
chess of course dukesh is already one of
the established elite players in the
world his live rating at 27.44 he will
be taking on Amen Ohanian and Iman is a
super Talent from Armenia Robert he's
only an international Master but he's
got two GM Norms you cannot write him
off yeah I think he's about to become a
grand master in a few months his title
will be verified so I think for Ohanian
you know he's beaten Grand Masters
before has he beaten super Grand Masters
that's a different question altogether
but this is speed chess and honey is one
of the best players on chess.com he is
super talented he is super fast he is
experienced in all time controls he was
in the recent OES the Olympic Sports
Series so he has what it takes to take
down a player like Google but it
certainly will not be easy
it's gonna be a big fight but drop it
for all practical purpose it's clear I'm
chap you want to hear it from you as
well that gukesh is a big favorite by
the Numbers here whether it's the rating
him being a grand master the hot streak
that gokish has been on
and I want to ask you this question what
does Eman do today to make this
difficult for gokish well we see the
smarter chess predictions everybody
who's watched this kind of commentary
for knows I disagree with them no matter
what they say but 1810 prediction in
gukesh's favorite time and I don't know
about you that sounds reasonable at
least at first glance to me I I can't
believe I'm agreeing but gukesh is the
favorite but that also shows that
Ohanian 22 chance that feels about right
you're such a rebel about the smarter
chess predictions Robert but yes this
time at least on paper it feels like it
is on point but Sports is not about
what's on paper it is about what happens
on that particular day and how much form
the players bring in as we can see in
the five plus one portion of the match
the prediction is six and a half to two
and a half where it goes on to the
shorter time control of three minutes
with just a one second increment it's
63. Robin I think for even the best
chance is to take it into that bullet
potion the one plus one with as least of
a margin that he can manage because the
bullet we all know one plus one is
absolute Randomness yeah it's a
different ball game as they say it
Hikaru is actually spoken about this a
lot when he plays in the speeches
Championship he feels that if he's
within you know two three games he has a
great chance against anybody and I think
for Ohana that's the Striking Distance
that he needs to enter the bullet down
at most three games because you can't
Trail by more than that in this
relatively short bullet streak so I
think for Ohana that's the number three
point deficit is the maximum he can face
against just to have a realistic chance
I mean we can't really even talk about
Hikaru him against anyone in the world
no matter what the deficit is the guy is
just brilliant he can make a comeback
from any situation but absolutely
foreign today going into that bullet
portion he needs to keep the margin as
narrow as possible and in the OnePlus
One no one cares about the predictions
no one cares about who is a favorite on
paper anything can happen it's Madness
which chat for us means absolute
entertainment
it certainly does who doesn't love a
good speed Chess Championship this one
brought to you by the junior speed chess
champions in the making and I I really
think that we're starting with such a
great measure because gukesh he's shown
his promise on the international stage
at the Olympia the gold medal he earned
on board one for his individual
performance and I mean his accolades
they're amazing and he's just 17.
you need multiple slides to actually
show the kind of performances that gkesh
has had over the last couple of years
he's also fresh out of a brilliant
performance at Norwich has when he where
he finished third he also had a great
run earlier this year at the WR Masters
you pointed out the Olympiad he's a gold
medalist he's the one who led the team
India B into the podium in the 2022
Olympiad he's won so many events and
Robert at all of 17 his live rating
currently is two seven four four he's
world number 13. that's insane yesterday
our number was 0.9 seconds for Eduardo
terzaga today it's 2744 and you
mentioned the gold that gukesh has won
look at it behind him and to his side he
has won so many trophies I'm sure that's
just a fraction of the trophies he's won
but he wants to add one more maybe it
won't be a physical trophy but he'll
take the dollars and he wants to win
another title
that looks like a divide duty-free to me
that is a lot of gold going on there
Robert I'm loving it we've been talking
about sitting in a place and playing
where you can find all the inspiration
that's a room that you want to sit in
you know that you're going for the big
wins here and gakesh there looking
determined for this one a big heavy
favorite but again for the underdog Iman
Ohanian it means there's no pressure he
just has to do his best he's not as well
as known as gakacious but he's been
having a hot streak of his own take a
look at that at the very strong Sharjah
Masters in the challengers group he won
that he's all of 16 years old he's won
several youth championships including
the European under 16 Championship as
well so he's definitely someone you
can't sleep on gakesh needs to strike he
needs to strike soon he needs to strike
big the cookies is clear he has to make
sure he brings home as many points as
possible in the five plus one and the
three plus one yeah I mean Gucci he's
talented no matter how much time he has
on the clock it really doesn't matter
he's so strong but what you don't want
to do is give your opponent who your
high risen confidence by saying allowing
them to win the first game because then
they feel you know what I can do this
not oh this position looks difficult but
my opponent's so strong I don't think I
can manage it I think that Ohanian the
start that he gets is really important
and for gukesh you want to exert that
super Grand Master Force you want to
show off your skills and you want to get
out to an early lead
Robert did you say do you search did you
just see the room that
gets right there let's take a look at
the time control the format a four the
junior speed Chess Championship it is
the signature chess.com speed chess
championship format as we see 19 90
minutes of five minutes with a one
second per move increment then we'll
have an over of three minutes with a one
second family increment and then finally
30 minutes of Madness one minute with a
one second increment
and the players will finish the game
that they start before the timer runs
out and we can see the players are
getting ready Robert behind the scenes
they're about to start feeling the
nerves feeling the tension once it's get
go there's no looking back there's no
time to rest and there we got amen
Ohanian on the screen he's ready to take
on the Kish yeah he seems ready I like
the cabinets behind him uh you know this
Armenian youngster he is really strong
and I think sometimes you know when you
do not have the pressure as you
mentioned he is the eighth seed in this
event everybody expects gukesh to win
sometimes that can really help you
because you feel like I'm just playing
the game one move at a time and whatever
happens it's gonna be fun I'm gonna here
to have a good time but he's also here
to win I mean he is a very dedicated
player and I think we're about to have
liftoff
I'm gonna address the cabinets in the
room here Robert two very different
sides goodkish with a lot of gold behind
him em and Ohanian looking to fill up
his own cabinet and this could be the
day it starts as we've been mentioning
the past winners of the junior speed
Chess Championship have gone on to
establish themselves in the world Elite
and this is a huge platform Arjun
aragasi is the reigning the current
Junior speed Chess Championship Champion
he defeated nehal Serene last year and
this one's going to be a big big fight
starting today and this is the match
that we kick off with yeah we might as
well name our previous Champions Wei was
the first Junior speeches Champion then
we had Nihao winning two in a row and
Arjun upset mihal a year ago to take the
title so we have some superstars who
have won this event and gukesh he's
already there he's amongst the world's
lead firmino hanyan if he could take
down good cash I mean who knows the
future holds for him it's already a
great successful career at just 17 but I
think he can add more to that cabinet as
you said because maybe that's a sign
maybe he's signaling it's empty right
now because I want to keep adding to it
so it's always going to be empty as I
look for more
it's gonna be interesting to see if he
starts filling it up today itself we've
got liftoff action is on gakesh starts
with the white pieces and wow we see a
kind of a Catalan with black deciding to
go fan shadowing as well Robert I'm not
sure did this come from a slob did it
come from a Catalan what happened here
it came from Knight F3 on move one just
to quickly go through the moves and we
had a sort of ready set up and then
black decided to feed and keto as well
so a very solid start to this game as we
hop forward to the live position black
protecting the pawn on D5 and now that
we're here Tanya I mean this looks like
very normal stuff white plays Knight H4
trying to force some of the issues here
in the center and well capture on D2
Queen takes dude that would look weird
but Tanya you know in these types of
positions you could play Queen 62
because the bishop on C1 may have other
diagonals to work with
and the diagonal that you're looking at
Robert is on the left side of the board
the Queen side you want to push that
beep on ahead and land up with your
Bishop on B2 or even potentially on A3
eyeing that E7 Pawn dukesh goes on to
get more control more space in the
center coming on with Tempo already
about 40 seconds up on the clock not
looking easy for amen no these pawns
they can be menacing but on the other
side they maybe are our targets we
sometimes you're like oh can I push that
pawn back to E3 let me get a pawn chain
so this D4 Pawn needed defense that's
why the Knight left the rim back towards
the center and then it begs the question
is Bishop G4 in time oh there might be
Rook D1 so instead a man just develops I
think this is sensible Queen B6 bring a
rook to d8 things of that nature so tell
me I feel like there's going to be a lot
of tension in the center
I love it already
all Russian is exactly the
immediately perhaps strike with C5
you've been pointing out that Bishop on
G7 that's the big Trump in Black's
position you want to open it up you want
to challenge White's Center as quickly
and as strongly as possible
and he goes for Queen B6 and the eval
bar reacted in White's favorite so I
think you're right timing that C5 looked
like the way to go uh but perhaps I mean
didn't like the trades in the center C5
now well there's no pin this bishop was
protected also this Pawn can go up to D5
so Rook d8 he is playing to keep that
tension in the center he's just saying
maybe your Pawn D4 is more of a weakness
rather than a strength in the long term
Italian Bishop G4 at some moment really
could hurt White
and especially once White's Rook lands
on D1 to try to defend the D4 pawn
bishop G4 is a pin you don't want some
nice tactic being set up there a battery
along the e1a5 diagonal Bishop A5 would
win the exchange on the spot as also a
strategic idea Robert here of putting
the queen from D2 all the way to B2 so
that it steps out of the way from that
Rook on d8 defends that default Pawn so
this is tactics combined with strategy
I'm liking Bishop C3 I think I mean
Capilli overlooked this idea and I have
to I didn't see it coming either but
this is really great stuff from Google
Queen on B6 is where it wants to be
putting pressure on D4 but if you don't
have time and you really need to play
Bishop G4 you have to spend another turn
moving your queen it's a bit awkward but
on the other hand Tanya this queen may
find his way over to H5 and that does
give black some chances to try to trade
off light Square Bishop so she's like I
heard you no no light Square Bishop
trades for black
yeah it actually looks like that that
you Robert right now did the queen H5
what queen H5 I got G4 coming in at some
point you're not gonna get your Bishop
on H3 so again some good preemptive
prophylactic play there by gokish for
Ohanian it's all about trying to find
his counter play and it's not easy in
these positions what you really want is
to strike in the center with a potential
F5 or C5 but that means more weaknesses
for black uh Robert it's a bit of a
Suffocation strategy that gokish has
going on here it's a great way of
framing it that black just does not have
space doesn't have squares and Knight C5
taking advantage of a pin along the D
file but the evil bar really didn't like
that move and queen E1 maybe not the
best route but still a very good one so
it gets the question mark because there
was something better I wonder what move
was available because that looks like a
relatively natural move to me stepping
out of the pin but I wonder what do you
see Tanya instead of Queen E1 protecting
the E4 Pawn did you have a better option
there
and we see the eval bar kind of
stabilizes I think Queenie one is a very
very human approach in this position you
step away from the D file defend the E4
pawn and Robert Emanuel Alaska world
champion he said when you find a good
move look for a better one but in these
time formats when you've got just five
minutes on the clock when you find a
good move you very well don't play it
you see Queen E1 it keeps things con it
keeps things compact you defended E4 you
play that move as quickly as possible
but look at this Ohanian is making use
of a lot of pins on the board why could
not have picked up that Knight on C5 the
bishop on C3 was hanging he also puts
pressure on the E4 Pawn but right now
black doesn't have a good way to
actually capture E4 Queen E4 runs into
white picking up the piece on C5 if
black gets greedy with capturing on e4
with the Knight white can also jump on
with his own Knight to E5 raw but let's
show this trick that's available 95
comes up and after Bishop E5 there is a
big Intermezzo of picking up the Knight
with the bishop attacking the queen
winning the bishop on E5 on the next
move and winning the game that's a
really beautiful tactic that the
Intermezzo is essential and that's why
we see instead of a capturing E4 the
Knight hopped back to A6 so it's clear
that ohanian's strategy has not worked
out look at White's beautiful Center
everything is defended in the position
uh The Rook protects the bishop in case
it needs an extra Defender but at the
same time this Rook on F1 is not in play
Tanya if Rook could jump over the queen
to D1 I think White's already just
completely winning but unfortunately
your queen can't move out of the way so
White's pieces stepping on each other's
toes but black doesn't have time I'm
looking at the clock and the position I
think Ohio is in big trouble
Rook G1 you put that Rook jump it over
Castle the queen and you're absolutely
winning the bishop falls back on F1 you
start pursuing the Queen the queen
doesn't even have great squares in the
position but that's the only challenge
that gakesh has right now everything
else is placed beautifully controlled on
the center the B3 A2 these two pawns on
the queen side really limit Black's
light squared Bishop what is Ohana's
other problem is that Knight on A6 it's
really not playing currently and gokish
taking advantage of the moment jumps in
with his own Knight the one thing that
black doesn't want to do is give up his
fan chat or Bishop for this Knight on E5
because that would create a lot of dark
squared weaknesses but Robert if that's
not an option if the queen has to fall
back kakesh is already thinking about an
F Pawn marching down the board F4 F5
ideas and that's really scary for black
yeah he was thinking about whether or
not black captured so I mean says you
know what I'll grab it my knight now has
a square to jump back to because there's
no Pawn on D4 but Tana doesn't it feel
like black has moved back and forth back
and forth as Queen with the B6 to B5 to
D3 back this Knight went from A6 to C5
and back I just feel like black has
spent a lot of time Dilly dallying to
some extent and white is ready to strike
as you mentioned with F4 but when you
push pause forward you have to
acknowledge they don't move back there
could be over extension if white doesn't
strike at the right time
a lot of queen dancing there done by
Ohanian but it was also the need of the
other it's it's some or the need of the
minutes in this case the queen is the
only active piece that black has in the
position not much else to play with but
the one good news like you pointed out
is that the black and finally find
itself in the game Knight C5 Knight D3
but is it in time white wants to move
the king away and start pushing the F
Pawn this is a race can black jump in
with the Knight to D3 Robert I feel not
because F5 is coming in with a tempo
yeah who cares about this Rook on C1 F5
is too powerful F6 or E6 and queen H6
there's going to be a Checkmate attack
against the black cake
I love it E6 and that move that black
just page Rook D3 don't be fooled it's
not an attacking move what it wants to
do is sacrifice The Rook for that Bishop
on C3 if and when it's required because
White is coming for those dark squares
this is getting tricky F6 in the air E6
in the air not right now watch out Queen
G3 Robert
is that actually scary that's the big
question the queen takes G3 there's all
e takes F7 and all these ideas but I
like the way good cash is playing this
even if they're he sacks his own
exchange and the reason why the Knight
can't get back but he missed Queen takes
G3 ideas and it's a check but how are
you guarding the mate on G7 you can give
a check I fall back in H1 what's your
move this queen takes H3 it's oh this is
unbelievable we need to bring up an
analysis where only three seconds left
for black and this is why gukesh is
thinking after he takes F6 you're
threading made in one it looks
impossible stop Queen G3 if you play
King G1 Queen E3 forces the Queens off
the board and king h1o's queen takes H3
check and after Bishop takes Rook H3 you
force the Queen off the board you stop
the Checkmate and suddenly it is black
who is up material I told you Tanya you
do not want to give the underdog
confidence and all of a sudden Amino
hunting should be very confident because
he's proving right here right now that
he can out calculate even with three
seconds on his clock the mighty go cash
this is insane what a turnaround this is
gokish now going into a thing tank but
it might be too late and he can't go for
the intended idea goes Rook F3 but now
you can go Queenie one and at least
Force to draw here but maybe there's
more Rook H3 ideas is he going to find
more than a Perpetual Robin can you go
quit
show that yeah oh the new game is
starting very quickly here uh but I
actually can pull up the previous I'm
just gonna show it very quickly while
the new game gets underway I mean that
is a fantastic line by you Tanya it's so
hard to see these ideas when you have
two seconds but Queen F2 check is your
point and after King H2 Rook takes H3
the bishop cannot take that as illegal
because it's pinned you have to give up
your queen for the rook and that's just
gonna lose the game so instead it looks
like King to H1 would have been
necessary and this I guess is where he
struggled is there it takes H3 check or
you just take on F6 no it's even easier
you just take the pawn that is
threatening Checkmate and black is up
two Rooks for just the bishop that would
be winning so good find by you really
hard to spot on the Fly and we are
getting in to game two and here we go
Robin I don't know if you noticed but MN
ohanya
his head after that result I think he
immediately realized what he missed and
that was a big moment because taking the
lead so early on things could completely
turn around the predictions would be in
the Dustbin by now but kokesh after
having a winning position survives at
the very end
but you have to give credit to Ohana and
he was just completely busted he had no
time and yet he saw it through he saw
the main tactics and that's why he was
able to survive he didn't win the game
as you're saying that would have been
huge for him but look at this position
he is white in game two he's created a
great Pawn chain in the center and he's
just playing solid strong chest so I
feel like I mean confidence Edge that's
good for oh hunting here now he needs to
make the most of it he needs to get a
good position like he has now and he
needs to maximize so that's a good
question I'm gonna pose to you Tana
you're a D4 player through and through
this looks great to my eyes how do you
make it more from aesthetically pleasing
to a legit Advantage you like that move
Queen B5
I do like it because if black was to
type yes you can
you can write but it all
so you can take it with the pawn open up
the a file and the A7 Pawn would be a
long-term weakness so capturing on B5
would be a big strategic mistake which
is why gkesh falls back with the queen
one of the ideas that you want here is
to push off push back that black
centralized Knight on E5 how do you do
that for him and oh honey and he can't
start considering the little move H3
taking control of the G4 Square first
and then go for F4 so that the Knight
doesn't have the G4 jump
yeah that is very principled in this
line it's the Matic H3 take away the
square then F4 don't rush F4 that would
be a huge blunder to Knight G4 and the
bishop has nowhere good to go and this
bishop on G7 it's waiting in the wings
it's you know long term that's a huge
Plus in Black's position once the
diagonal clears up a bit but for now it
is amino hanyan spending time so in game
one he did this he spent a lot of time
in the early stages in game two he's
like I have three minutes left right now
in normal Blitz Games that I play I
start with three minutes so he is
probably using this clock like he
wouldn't ordinarily just because he has
more additional time to begin with but
ton he needs to find a plan he's better
it looks good it's that benoni structure
but what is his actual idea right now
well Black's got a clear threat right
we've been talking about age
night on D3 and try and look for counter
player on the queen side as well Eminem
first starts with trying to narrow down
on the queen side just get more control
A5 also eyeing a further push to A6 to
create some more light squared
weaknesses eventually he really wants to
start playing on the king side with A3
F4 coming in meanwhile the gokish the
plan is to push the C Pawn try and get
the other Knight to C5 jump into D3
Robert I wouldn't be surprised if we see
C4 on the board
yeah and I think Bishop F2 was played
because he was worried about another
punch like F5 and that Bishop was a bit
loose on E3 sometimes that you know is
something to look for and Bishop too I
don't see why it's a bad move but
because of your plan Tanya black is
doing A-Okay C4 is playing that Knight
now coming to D3 with a shot against
this bishop and that Bishop on G7 we're
you know saying it was waiting in the
wings now it's about to have a fully
open diagonal and unleashes potential do
not give that dog Squad bishop and
that's an advice for both white and for
black hair you really want to keep these
two pieces and Tack and only trade it
for each other Knight D3 is a big threat
but what I'm really worried about is
immense time right now he's under two
minutes on the clock meanwhile a gokish
with over four minutes and this can
really count when the position gets
complicated with so many pieces on the
board it's going to happen it's bound to
happen but Robert what image showed in
round one is that even with seconds on
the clock he can really calculate it
fast and be precise
yeah but it's one of those situations
where it's like fooled me once all right
you got me it's not gonna happen again
that's good cash for you he let one slip
you know he had a winning Advantage he
was really going for checkmate and he
didn't find the correct variation but
look at this position it already just
looks to my eyes great for black I don't
need the eval bar at zeros I'm looking
at this with all of the potential for
blacks Knights here it seems good and
then you look at the clock and it's
three extra minutes and then some for
good cash I mean it needs to play
quicker this is not going to get it done
against cash a hundred percent because
the last game had Emin had a couple of
extra seconds he would have definitely
found the killing blow and that's what
it comes down to those extra minutes on
the clock for googesh saved him in that
position and now we see he's under a
minute on the clock plays the move Rook
to B1 what he wants to do is go B3 and
get out of the stronghold that the Black
Knight has on D3 but Robert usually in
the same-ish kind of positions that's
not the direction that you want you want
to start pushing in the center
yeah look at this Rook see see there's
no pressure against this Pawn anymore so
Knight D3 is about to happen he goes
Rook A4 trying to get this Pawn if you
play Knight D3 I'm going to take on C4
but it's not the best move that's clear
with the question mark and one idea that
comes to mind is a pretty natural Knight
to C5 there's Bishop H6 ideas kicking
this Knight out of here so Knight D3 is
next I I feel like this game has gone
completely wrong for amino hanyan
I love Knight CFO because it almost
forces white to actually recapture with
the bishop on F2 giving up this dark
Squad Bishop making a monster of blacks
Bishop on G7 Rook A4 has a question mark
but it's already a very difficult
situation here four MN things have gone
wrong with what with the white pieces
barely seconds on the clock and gokish
wanting to keep the Queens on the board
I think he's also playing on the Block
it doesn't matter what the objective
evaluation is he just wants to keep as
much material as possible on the board
yeah look at these Knights this Knight
comes to C5 please take my knight on C5
and it's to happen in King F1 and no
this can't be good and the evil Bar says
though this is horrible for white
because that was a Miss but this is
what's happening with Google plays
quickly maybe he's playing too quickly
right that's something that we can and I
think it's a Justified criticism and
thus far or maybe a suggestion more than
a criticism is that when he gets these
winning advantages he should just win on
the board rather than trying to rush it
and also use the clock
yeah it's always such a tough balance to
find those critical moments when to stop
when you're in the pace of moving
quickly and I think as so far the time
management has worked in gakash's favor
Knight D1 and this is where he pauses to
have a thing he can feel it he's placed
all his pieces in an Optimum position
now he's looking for a way to break
through does he jump in with the Knight
to D3 but he's got to calculate tactics
because Knight D3 it might look like a
move you want to make but white can
perhaps just capture on C4 and there
might be complications the White Knight
can jump on E3 targeting the C4 Pawn
further so it doesn't really get
anything for black where is the break is
he thinking about a potential
F5
yeah no I'm looking at F5 for sure let's
open up more lines for your piece look
at this Rook on 84 right it's doing one
thing and one thing only hitting this
Pawn on C4 and that pawn is quite well
defended so you might have time to play
Move Like F5 Bishop H6 if you want to
kick this Knight out of here so C4 never
feels vulnerable that's an idea as you
mentioned Knight D3 of course will
always be an option and he goes Queen E7
he wants queen H4 but the eval bar
doesn't love it
doesn't love it but I mean we're just
six seconds on the clock makes the move
Rook C1 further targeting the C4 Pawn
but now the black queen can find itself
on G5 on H4 the bishop 86 idea that you
mentioned in the previous moves comes
with more horsepower here Bishop 86
would be a huge pin on the diagonal he
starts with queen H4 this is getting bad
and this is what happens when a player
has more space and better place pieces
you can jump around from one side of the
board quickly to the other we see the
queen has landed on H4 there's a mate in
one a big threat I don't see how you're
fighting it if you move the Knight there
was a mate on F2 and that's it I mean
resigns that one he had no time left on
the clock and now the case starting with
the javawa London
yeah no he's going for the jabal London
trying it out and that was a nice game
from gookesh I mean he didn't do
anything fancy at first played an
opening that according to the engines
was slightly better for white but then
he found all of the good ideas while his
opponent Amino Hanan was just moving
pieces back and forth it didn't seem
like he had a concrete plan so thus far
I would say good cash is with excellent
chess overall with the exception of
overlooking that tactic in game one in
game two he slowed down at that right
moment he brought Quinn to E7 to H4 and
eventually he delivered a checkmating
attack so Knight comes to C6 kind of
early stages here of this Jabara London
I think that uh for gukesh he's playing
one of his uh you know Blitz opening
repertoires but what do you make of it I
mean do you like it because I always
have a problem when I put my knight in
front of my own pawn it feels like I'm a
little cramped at least more than I
should be
it's one of those openings that with
black when you're facing the jababa
London if you don't know what you're
doing you can get into trouble really
quickly it's not an opening of choice
for me with the white pieces but I think
if you're well prepared you're ready to
handle it because very often a white
would not be able to get too much
Advantage out of the opening but also
Robert it comes into what format in a
classical game sure you can handle
anything think take your time but when
it's down two minutes on the clock when
we're talking Blitz we've seen London
and the jababa London gain so much in
popularity because all of that is thrown
out of the window it becomes an opening
that's not as easy to answer
and you see by Amino heinens think there
it wasn't easy for him to answer this
opening he plays Bishop G4 uh one thing
that he wants to do is let E6 and win
this opponent C5 but you know that he's
looking out for Knight A4 type of idea
so first we see like give up the light
score bishop and then play E6 rather
than E5 this is a very instructive
moment many people would have lashed out
and played E5 attacking the bishop
thinking that you win a Tempo but you
really do is cause yourself a problem on
D5 so this Pawn chain is essential a
pawn chain is only as strong as its base
pawn and this Pawn on D5 is what white
is trying to Target anyway so don't push
your Pawn up to E5 too soon that's over
extension that would have cost black
some material
and a really nice point there as well of
giving up the light squared Bishop
because he wanted the queen on F3 and
Robin if it's possible we just go back
one move uh before going long castle if
White had actually tried to defend the
C5 Pawn there was a check on A5 picking
up that Knight here because the queen is
not is not on D1 so there's no C3 on the
board and that's the reason that amen oh
hanyan decided to go Bishop G4 trade off
the Bishops and then go for this plan
let's get up to date with the live
current quote that we've got we've got
long Castle Queen comes to A5 so still
delaying picking up the C5 Pawn but the
drawback of that move is that the F6
Knight is tender and you have to spend
one more move maybe fall back with the
Knight to D7 but things are getting a
little slow in terms of development for
black so maybe just develop with Bishop
E7 my first instinct because I see the
eval bar go to minus one is there some
kind of Knight E4 the good news for the
players is they don't have the eval bars
that can trick you sometimes you see
that oh it's good for me I must go
forward and I thought Knight E4 to
distract this night away from eventually
Queen takes A2 would be on the table but
Knight D7 you suggested it it is a good
idea you're just trying to win the C5
Pawn back then I can go to E5 and this
bishop is staring Into Thin Air there's
nothing it's attacking but whoa and this
is what I was scared about it's a great
idea I have Knight D5 doesn't work and
this is definitely something to keep in
mind because black has lack of
development the king is in the center
and dukesh goes for it he goes for this
this is going for blood pick it up with
the queen you're threatening that Knight
on D7 and Robert how are you defending
this
well I think you can play Queen C7 but
it's I feel at you I'm like barely
hanging on because of all these threats
and I'm wondering did Black have a move
there if we just go back and analyze for
a second uh e takes D5 it gets that uh
Mark there because it misses the mark
what you needed to do I think was throw
in Knight E5 first attacking this queen
and then the queen goes up to E4 and
only then if you want to you can take
this Knight on D5 and you've kind of
gained a Tempo in a way where if this
Rook takes on D5 you play F6 it's it's
uncomfortable but black has some counter
threats Queen E1 check Queen takes a two
things of this nature and for the moment
black would be up a piece for three
pawns it's a material imbalance a very
tricky position but I do think that
throwing a knight to forward with E5 it
could have saved black a Tempo and maybe
made his defensive task a little bit at
least more natural to my eyes
that's a really great point to make and
it's often these inter mezzers that you
miss because it's so natural and the
human tendency to just recapture
immediately especially in these quick
formats you don't take that pause it's
kind of like the hand move that you make
and this might cost a lot for Emin
Ohanian currently after Queen D5 he does
pick up the pawn with C5 the C5 pawn and
now Bishop C4 bringing another piece to
the party queen F7 is a big threat has
to fall back defends it
Robert it looks dangerous but at least
for the moment I don't see a killer blow
for white no I don't either and White's
best move is take this E Pawn and throw
it off the board get out of here so you
get a rook E1 check because if you could
deliver a check on E1 I think the game
is Just crushing in White's favor
because the bishop would never be able
to go to E7 and this is the main point
is that white has all of this Firepower
going after the black king side so I
think Queen D7 or queen E7 are your only
two moves here not easy to choose
between them Tanya Queen D7 offers a
queen trade that obviously white is not
going to accept and then you have to
move your queen again once the White
Queen moves out the way but Queen E7
delays your development further because
your Bishop 108 can't get out Tonya I
don't know which is better but which
would you choose
yeah it's definitely choosing between
the two lesser evil trying to find the
Lesser evil and he decides to go with
the queen to E7 not walking into any
discovered ideas with that Rook on D1
and dukesh keeping the momentum on the
clock and Robert I can feel your energy
you're leaning forward right now because
you know how dangerous this position is
the C5 Knight is hanging but I love this
move Rook to d8 so just for everyone
who's watching this gaming confused with
all this these pieces that are hanging
and threatening things this queen on E7
is needed here to defend the F7 Pawn so
that's what queen takes D6 was not
available but now after Bishop takes E7
Rook takes D5 what will happen is black
will give up this Rook
and get a piece in return that's a bad
trade but remember black is already up a
piece for a couple pawns so we will
likely see a material imbalance Tanya
where black will have two minor pieces
for a rook and a couple pawns Black's
King still not completely safe it's
going to be an interesting let's call it
a queenless middle game it's not quite
an end game just yet
yeah usually the side that's got the two
minor pieces Against The Rook you want
the Queens on the board because the main
idea is to try to create play and
activity against your opponent's king if
it's an end game decide with the rook
and the extra pawns is the one that has
an advantage and the winning chances
yeah and I'm doing the math it's not one
extra Pawn it's two pawns on a rook for
two minor pieces Robert in these endings
especially with the black queen side
pawns being weak as well why doubling it
on the D file for MN o'hanian he needs
to struggle for a draw here kokesh I
think is playing for two results this
position
yeah look at the clock as well that's
not gonna help oh hunting but what might
help is this move F5 and the Knight to
E4 he's suddenly giving his pieces some
squares and your best move is A6 back to
B7 sorry that's not legal but to your
point you want to connect your pawns you
don't want these isolated pawns on the
queen side so look at gukash playing
small moves with his Pawn C3 A5 was
played by black it's hard to get to
Black's pawns Tanya I feel like this is
an ideal defensive setup for Ohanian
absolutely and at some point white has
to strike with the Jeep on all the way
to G4 and try and create more weaknesses
on the king side you've got Rooks what
you want are open files you want files
and ranks with which you can attack your
opponent's pieces and I see a question
mark on that move but Bishop d8 Returns
the favor there was something better
that black had there
yes and I I'm only getting a clue
because there was a question black was
with the advantage just very quickly it
was a tactic just to show that instead
of Bishop to d8 Knight to B6 was
available Rook takes a five Knight C4
hitting this rook and threatening a fork
on E3 this is kind of outside the box
not easy to spot and we're only helped
because the engine says up there was a
missed opportunity there but this still
looks like black is really trying to
hold I actually think that black is in
trouble because your minor pieces can't
move the Bichon did stuck here and if
you move your Rook away you'll lose the
C6 Pawn so I don't see a plan for black
just yet
a lot more because E5 E6 is also in the
air so black had to detangle untangle
himself for
CES on the d-line Now The Rook is
targeting the A5 pawn and maybe still
he's got this idea of Knight B6 Knight
C4 but the big difference there Robert
is that white has a check on it
right so there would not be a fork on E3
just yet that is something that black
wants so bring this Knight to D5 that
should help stabilize white does not
want to put upon C4 because you hand all
the dark squares to Black so white will
like put B4 and A5 and just restrict the
enemy Bishop while pushing your past
pawns uh this move Rook A7 directly
attacks the pawn on A4 you can defend by
going for a counter threat or by pushing
your Pawn to A5 but I feel like these
positions Tanya are still quite tricky
as long as there's a night on the board
it's always tricky because there are
Forks in the air you just never know
what's going to happen but so far that
Knight on f8 you know that it's not the
most dangerous piece it's not been able
to find those checks on the board uh
hits The Rook says you can take the C6
Pawn but in return white will have to
give up the A5 Pawn
the two passes on the queen side which
is nine seconds on the clock rub it it's
going to be a miracle if Emin survives
this one it will be but at least there's
some clarity that's the good thing when
you don't have a lot of time you need a
clear plan Rook G5 and after G4 Pawn H5
things of this nature come to mind so
suddenly I see ideas working to check
taking on G2 he can go for this Pawn but
good guesses I don't care about the
quantity look at how good this passer is
how you're gonna stop it it's just going
the other side
that's a great question that's going to
be assisted by by its best friend which
is the C Pawn the C4 C5 advances always
in the air if required to defend the
spawn Rook B5 is a threat he could start
with the move C4 he starts instead with
the King uh advance to A4 taking control
of B5 I don't see a way of stopping the
pawn from queening Robert and he lost
some time he didn't see a move and so he
now is down by two points two wins in a
row for gukash this is not what you want
for amino honey a great start with that
first draw it was a shaky game but the
result was there but now with the white
pieces Tanya he cannot afford to lose
three in a row he needs to get at least
a draw here and I think he needs to
exert some pressure because we haven't
seen him with a better position outside
of when gukesh blundered in game one
a hundred percent and as we see our
features chat there uh escan saying that
gokish will try and dominate this one
that's exactly what he's doing and
Robert as you mentioned a third loss in
the row it's not just about the score
line psychologically in this format it
is so difficult to come back from that
you're just going to a spiral go into a
tilt and with no time to recover it's
only downhill from there this is the
moment that Emma ohanya needs to stop
the pleading whether it's somehow to
keep the fort to hold the fort with the
draw or to try and win this game but
with the white pieces the one good news
that is that Robert for the first time
he's got control on the clock yeah he
has control on the clock he has control
in the center look at this D5 square and
white has one two three four pieces all
staring at this Square so that may lead
black with this backwards Pawn but I
like this bishop on E5 that's a great
piece it's hitting the 9f4 directly
maybe putting pressure down on the H2
Pawn so I don't have great experience
with either color in this position of
course I've commentated enough chess in
my life to have seen it many times uh
but one of the big questions that I'm
asking myself is do I want to play
Knight E6 and go into Bishops of
opposite color territory what do you
think would you play the move 96 or
maybe just a simple Knight D5
it all just comes down to what are the
options here a knight E6 I think given
the fact that white that black does have
uh the bishop pair is definitely
something that he considered but instead
he goes for the D5 Square Robert very
often in this position the fight is for
that D5 Square you want a piece over
there to keep things together to keep
everything under control but what does
what this does allow is the F Pawn to
March down the board you have to time it
well because an F4 move runs into a
check on G4 every pawn moves leaves
behind a weak square and that's what
happens if black does Rush with F4 that
Bishop on E5 for gukesh is a great piece
it can't be challenged but right now
with white space activity everything in
a dynamic balance as long as black
cannot play F4 white is fine here yeah
and I think black strategically is in
some trouble as you mentioned F4 is a
move that is very likely to backfire in
these positions it's okay for the moment
but you see gukesh he says F4 that looks
too risky and instead plays the move
King to h8 I think that makes perfect
sense he's also getting out of this
diagonal he's getting out of the check's
way and that way where he could play
Bishop takes B3 as this wasn't
immediately a check so interesting
moment here Tanya where we're gonna see
a knight that's going to get to D5
Knight C6 by the way is a possibility
here if you want to uh keep this Knight
on the board but then Bishop takes D1
Knight takes d8 and I don't know who
that works out for it's one of these
really complicated you take me I take
you we keep going with it but I do think
he can just take on B3 and after Queen
E7 put this Pony on D5 but that Bishop
on E5 is so strong for black
five right here
it is one of those positions by both
pieces or power houses here the Knight
on D5 is white Trump the bishop on E5 is
blackstrump it'll come down to whether
black can get those Central pawns
rolling or will white be able to find
play on The Queen side against the A6 B5
potential weaknesses Bishop B3 on the
board and again the one thing Ohanian
has to do is not take too much time
don't burn the clock if he feels that
capturing on B3 just keeps the balance
he should go for it instead he goes
Knight C6 and Robert
it's a mistake and it's a commentator's
curse because I was about to you were
talking and I realized my own mistake
and I was going to admit it and then he
plays Knight C6 I'm like wait a second
there's Bishop takes H2 just to dial it
back for a moment you couldn't take on
it sure that was a brilliant shot from
gookesh because if you take Queen to H4
is check the King has to move back to G1
and then the queen on D1 is lost so it
was in oversight I spoke it into in
existence and after King H1 Queen H4
your queen is under attack and once this
bishop moves Queen H2 will be Checkmate
so I'm sorry I mean my apologies I know
I said Knight C6 was possible but it
clearly was a bad move and I missed it
the first time but unfortunately for him
you know I'm not playing I can take it
back he cannot
fall trumpet that this happened I
remember
Agnes where you call that Bishop C7 the
Epic moment I think I'm short shot knows
about it and remembers it as well so
again it's down on you I'm mentioning
the move Knight C6 and it was all game
over you either lose your queen or run
into a checkmate at that point and
finally uh Emin decides to move on to
try and save some time get as many games
in as possible and that means three
losses in a row for MN
and you know it's way too early to match
to say oh he can't make a comeback but
he needs to start somewhere and he needs
to start soon because while they're 54
minutes left in this longest time Patrol
five minute plus one second increment
he's probably his biggest disadvantage
in this time Patrol right this is not uh
more time on the clock better for the
stronger player and gukesh is the
stronger player between the two that's
not up for debate uh but Amino hanyan
he's about to be a grand master very
strong in his own right he needs to find
his footing he needs to get some kind of
advantage and he just needs to play one
complete game that's what he needs for
himself
and by complete what you mean is a game
where he feels his flow he's better and
he's able to get that win that's the
confidence boost that you need Robert
I've been in emin's uh situation
position in the I am not a GM and it's
such a difficult psychological battle
you lose a few games in a row and it's
just hard to come back it's a spiral
from there and it takes a lot of uh
strength of character to be able to do
that but Eman has to make sure he
strikes back soon it's not an easy task
he's playing the black pieces and right
now with the given situation if he can
find a way to just stop the bleeding
stop the losing at the moment think
about the wins later just keep things
under control and get out with a draw in
this one that would be big success but
it looks like to me that gukesh is going
for it that last move Knight D5 it
offers a peace trade but black doesn't
really want to take on D5 because white
will recapture with the E Pawn and you
see that E7 weakness that's going to be
a weakness for the rest of the game
rookie one coming in too much trouble
and I would already feel that the
advantage is Shifting the momentum is
Shifting and it's towards Caucasian this
one yeah the first game gukesh you know
kind of had a winning position and let
it slip but then Amin could not fully
capitalize though he scored the half
point but you know when you get a draw
like that you feel good that you didn't
lose but you feel kind of bad because
like I got lucky I need to you know
outplay my opponent so that is what's
missing thus far and amino hunting is
capable of outplaying gukesh the mighty
go cash the gukash who's got third place
in Norway chess whose live rating is
27.44 number 13 in the entire world not
number 13 and is a junior Player 13 in
the entire world Olympia gold medalist I
mean he's such a monster but what Amin
needs to do he needs to play faster
that's for sure and he also just needs
to you know find his confidence he needs
to be able to just put together a series
of strong moves where he's like you know
I'm feeling the flow as you said and I
just don't think he has that right now I
think he's lost his confidence a bit
because because of what's happened the
last three games
that's the hardest thing to do right now
is to not let gokish get into your head
and to find the confidence after the way
things have gone it's not just been the
result but also the momentum of the
games gokish has been in the driver's
seat from around one there was that
small moment where Emin had that shot
but it was just a couple of moves apart
from that it's always been kukesh
dominating in these four games and
that's the turnaround that Emma needs
and once again we see him go really down
on the Block two minute Advantage for
gokish centralized pieces that last move
rookie won again just playing against
the capture on D5 and if black can't
capture on D5 if that Knight remains
it's going to just stop all of Black's
counter plays going to tie down that
Queen on d8 defending the E7 square and
always eyeing the light squared
weaknesses around Black's King okay
immediately yeah I wonder if he was
thinking that black maple E5 to get rid
of that weakness and then take on D5
that actually was a pretty interesting
idea and I'm just gonna show what that
looks like and to your point Tanya the
reason why black never took on D5 just
to put that on the boards E7 is such a
big Target you see that black would be
in big trouble the Evo bars suggests
white is much better but I was thinking
that E5 at some moment and if the queen
moves anywhere Bishop takes D5 now
you're not scared of this in fact black
is you see strategically winning because
you have the dark Square control against
a bad Bishop so if you could push that
pawn to E5 that's something that Ohanian
needs to consider if the Knight goes
back to D5 at some point
really nice there so Knight C5 with the
threat forcesh to fall back with that a
monstrous dragon that wasn't a knight on
D5 and now he goes with the Rook to E8
just defending the E7 Pawn if it's
required uh once again the reason that
white has placed the Rook on B1 is that
he's fighting against emin's threat of
A4 how you want to meet A4 is with the
move B4 and that's only possible if
white does have that Rook on B1 so just
to understand why he's chosen that
square it's not a passive move but it's
just prophylactic and we see A3 to get
B4 in as you're saying that Rook on B1
is serving a critical purpose and black
is moved a bit back but now might be the
time for E5 it's not an easy move to
play because then D6 becomes a backwards
Pawn but what you really would love to
do is this one ever goes to A4 that
would be the end for white that
strategically would be terrible but but
you just sent it from 100 he's moved
back and forth back and forth in gukesh
he has but his Knight back to D5 it's
been a rinse and repeat but I don't know
he could play Knight C5 now but there is
B4 they consider so he goes Queen B6
offering the trade I need him to just
you know play a couple moves in the flow
of the game
and white falls back refusing the trade
B4 was again a threat not anymore and
then fighting that threat Knight
centralized on E5 C4 Pawn is tender
white doesn't have the option to go F4
because notice the pin on the diagonal
with the queen on B6 and perhaps uh
gukesh can start considering
sidestepping with the King and renewing
renewing the threat of getting F4 in and
I'm just wondering is Evan going to try
and get tricky with the move A4
A4 is definitely an option because you
want to get rid of this B3 pawn and
after the move A4 White's best move is
pawned back to A2 creating a full Pawn
chain so good eye by you that the C4
Pawn will be loose in many of these
positions King H1 definitely an idea
here trying to play F4 and maybe after
King H1 F4 there are Knight G4 type
ideas so you have to be a little bit
careful there but I guess it's not the
end of the world because white can push
H3 and maybe that's your point that it's
not it may look threatening all these
smothered Checkmate ideas you see in
puzzle Rush not going to happen in this
game and King H1 was playing for that
reason
it's on the boat and as you pointed out
F4 Knight G4 looks scary but the deeper
you go into it you realize it's only a
check on F2 you can push that Knight
further away with H3 and if the Knight
comes to F2 it'll only get trapped I'm
expecting f4 on the board that last move
H5 it eyes uh the Knight perhaps even
jumping back to eight six at some point
wire G4 I'm not really sure but the good
thing is that Emin played H5 fast he's
still down by a minute on the clock
Robert the plan that we were talking
about is on the board and I'm just
wondering is he gonna go forward just to
come back on the next move
well I'm looking at ideas for H3 I give
up the Knight because if you remove
these H pawns Rook h8 will be a
checkmating idea so I'm not sure if
rookie is not a good idea because then
you can play H4 yourself and try to go
for this attack because that white King
has no Escape square and what I want to
see from a minute it's not even just
about objective because obviously every
player wants to play the best moves that
they can but I just want to see him come
up with ideas and be confident and go
for it and queen F2 maybe the engine
doesn't like it so much but in Blitz
chess mistakes happen and I think
mistakes often happen when your king is
in danger and now the G3 pawns under
attack the queen trade is offered he's
saying you can win the piece is that
what you're about to say Tanya but that
looks scary for white
I would be tempted to go rookie too and
the good thing for gukesh is that he's
got the time on the clock so it's clear
that if white trades black recaptures
goes to D3 is a happy camper there the
Knight can find itself a safe on this
Quest but rookie 2 is the critical move
how dangerous is it a black dust pick up
the G3 Pawn white picks up the piece on
G4 but the king just hides on G1 and
gokish is calculating all these moves
it's burning the clock he's still up on
the clock but Robert I I don't see the
killer blow after uh sacrificing the
piece I think he's going to go for
rookie too and we're gonna have
fireworks he's doing the right thing by
Calvin though because we don't see it at
first and he probably is like you know I
think I can get away with it but then
you miss one idea in the line and you're
immediately lost so I think you know
he's going to work his way through it he
played rookie too but I think in this
position a rook h8 you just gotta start
making some moves here for black but
Queenie through was excellent I have to
say that way you get King F2 and queen
G3 if the queen goes stage two if you
could force the Queens off the board
then you're winning but if king of too
many Rook H3 so he goes here instead
I liking F1 because I think Rook H3 was
a big threat taking advantage of the pin
along the second rank there and now the
point is that yes you've got this H line
you've got a Pawn on G4 but how do you
continue the attack how do you continue
the initiative white can even play
really slowly maybe jump with the Knight
to D5 but also just a long-term idea to
show Rook D1 Rook D3 get the queen on G3
I'm just struggling to find how does
black continue the attack the momentum
well he tries to all his P's in the H
file but the king runs away that's a
king March I like data it's not
petrosion it's good cash and this queen
on A2 by the way is like trapped over
here so it's not participating in the
game and so go cash now up a piece for
just a couple pawns his King is safe and
he actually just takes this Queen off
the board I was saying I like what oh
honey is doing I don't like it anymore I
take it back everything that Google
catch did was perfect and for Ohanian he
tried a sneaky little attacking plan and
it didn't pan out
yeah this is heartbreaking because
Ohanian down to two seconds on the clock
he's down a queen for a rook there's no
attack there's no compensation this will
be his fourth loss in a row it seems
very likely unless he can get some kind
of checks in and he brings Rook to H1 so
he is doing a pretty good job of causing
some complications but Knight C3 what a
calm move by you instead he goes for the
aggressive F5 is there oh
there's some problems for the white king
where is he hiding he wants to go to E3
King D2 and King E3 is what he wants and
he's saying that I'm coming for your
king I'm not really sure because after
King E3 black can't pick up that F5 Pawn
what's going on here oh and he got
stingy four that's amazing Queen G6 was
a big threat but Rook G one great play
by oh honey in his time Rook F1 there's
Rook F2 oh he has a check-in H5
and then what because check here check
this Rook G7 back and this F5 Pawn isn't
some trouble This is complicated
and the good news for black is he's got
to come back with the Rook cause the E7
Pawn was Thunder he does exactly that
you can't really take on F5 because you
end up with a lost end game Knight F4
Robert it looks like ukesh has
calculated everything and now Knight E6
comes in Queen H3
oh 96 won the game on the spot if it
said he goes for checkmate here so how
can black stop it I don't think you can
the king successfully runs away and it
it oh it's made right no it's but you
win The Rook at least
and that should be enough to win the
game just go Queen G7 win The Rook give
the Checkmate on the next move and that
is it
that's game that's game over and with
that gokish wins the fourth game in a
row and again Robert in convincing style
we see him there
he's been on fire today from the very
start he's been unbelievable he made a
mistake in game one I was thinking maybe
that would give a hunting some chances
and Google now that's your only chance
thus far it has been a display of
Excellence from the youngster from India
he is a sensation and he's playing a
sensational match and that's why he's up
four points
and this is the halfway mark of the
first segment of the junior speed chess
championship of the five minute with the
with a one second increment we will be
back with more five plus one action
Eminem has a mammoth task in front of
him he's got to start scoring and he's
got to do it fast
[Music]
foreign
Chess Championship
defending Champion has defended his
title National Master Ryo Chen wins
match is over with this game exactly yes
wins the final three games to close out
this match
foreign
[Music]
you don't want to face this man right
now he's playing the junior speed Chess
Championship he's just 17 years old but
he is currently the world number 13
rated to 744 on a hot streak winning so
many events and there we see behind him
all the trophies providing all the
inspiration he needs and Robert he leads
with a four point margin right now what
Emma needs to do is not look at
gakisha's camera
yeah because you look at the trophies
like this guy's won a lot and I mean I
don't want to add to that trophy case at
least not in this match not today but
for me and Ohanian Tanya it's been a
really rough start it's kind of the
worst case scenario for him he did draw
game one that probably felt good at
least on paper but as you said it's not
just about what happens on paper in
competition it's about what happens in
the flow of the game and it's been all
gookish
he's been flowing like water today in
this match and rub it four and a half to
half we
we I mean being the underdog his best
chance being of getting into that bullet
one plus one segment with as narrow a
margin as possible and that plan isn't
working at currently a four-point lead
if gokish runs away with it which is
already on the way in the five plus one
it's gonna be really hard for Emin to
make to try and get a comeback it's not
just the score line it's a psychological
the inner game as well the Battle of
trying to recover of not letting your
opponent get into your head and I'm
afraid for Emin it's an uphill task
it really is and you know he's a such a
strong player very capable I think he's
getting some nourishment as he gets set
for the second half of the five minute
plus one second per move increment time
control and yeah he just needs to have a
complete game we've talked about this a
few times already but if he can just
string together a series of good moves
if he could just say I could outplay
this guy it can happen then he will
probably feel a lot better about his
chances but for now he hasn't outplayed
gukesh with the exception of that game
one blunder from who cash in a winning
position it's felt like just in complete
and utter control
well he got this little break in the
middle and I hope he's been able to
switch up his mindset the two battles
that he's been fighting is not just over
the board but the clock management as
well and that's something that's the
trickiest part it's definitely the 17th
piece in this uh format Robert and
Ohanian needs to make sure that's not a
narrative that gets repeated and I see
him doing that that's the good news he
has a played fast he's made the accurate
choices and I see that the queen on D4
the D file is open it gives white the
option to not only line up with the rook
and the queen but also notice how
White's Bishop can come to B2 and start
potentially threatening along the
diagonal as well the Knight jumps to E4
I'm eyeing some weaknesses there
it looks like this could go emin's way
yeah it's a good start to this game
that's for sure and the problem when you
play Gucci someone who's number 13 in
the world is his opening preparation is
Stellar his middle game execution is
fantastic his end games yeah he may be
young but not much of a problem there
either there are no weaknesses in
gukesh's game now relative to some other
elite players sure he may struggle to do
certain things uh everyone is growing
every chess player is a work in progress
but I think that's a big issue is when
you play somebody that's maybe your own
strength you say what direction do I
want to take this game when you play
someone who's better than you like you
know what you know I could maybe get
them in uncomfortable territory when you
play the number 13 player in the world I
don't think there's anything that's
uncomfortable for him he loves chess
he's great at it and so for amino
hunting he's just struggling to find
that direction and well he brings his
Queen in a good direction I would say
opening up an attack against the queen
on d8 and Tiny I'm looking at this
position and I'm with you I actually do
like it for white
and for a second I was just wondering
what are the squares that gagesh has for
the Queens not too many Robert which is
why he falls back with the Knight to D7
and it is an uncomfortable move to make
it already does imply and hint to us
that things haven't gone well so gokish
in the opening for MN of course he's
qualified into the junior speed Chess
Championship through the May qualifiers
it's his first time here in the mix it's
also a lot about experience he's got two
Grandmaster Noms he's been having
phenomenal performances in the opens
he's won so many youth championships so
he's definitely someone who's capable of
making that comeback and for him at the
end of the day it's also about gaining a
lot of experience I really like what
he's done so far in this game after that
shot break that he had Queen H5 eyeing
potential sacrifices on eight six and
look at that is that gkesh is he going
to repeat will he try and bail out
one interesting repetition this is but
it makes sense to me because where else
could the queen go from H5 back to H4
that looked a bit awkward entering The
Bishop's line of sight so we have seen a
repetition thus far and considering how
much time it means spent to play it I
don't think this is some kind of
preparation forcing draw sequence I
think he's just playing the current
position and
what do you think will he make this draw
he really shouldn't Robert he's got the
white pieces he's down by four points on
the scoreline he's and he doesn't I
think that's a very good decision and
this is the kind of fighting ambitious
play that's required from Emin right now
to fight uh the Titan that he's facing
currently with kukesh against him Queen
F4 a good choice by Amin yeah you know
what play 94 give up this A2 Pawn Play
Bishop B2 and that looks like a
promising attack I'm not even just
saying it because the scoreboard
although if I'm being honest we have to
take that into account already at this
stage like sometimes you feel I need to
play for a win I need to get a w I need
to narrow the Gap from four to three but
I just think this is principal play you
go over towards the king side and this
black king on G8 doesn't have too many
Defenders around it and the queen side
is lacking for black there isn't
development there the pieces are Tangled
Up
I like that move the knight from E4 also
stops any potential Bishop G5 Queen G5
trading ideas and once the bishop lands
in the on the diagonal it will be a fire
piece Robert what Edmond has to make
sure is again not to take too much time
at this moment because it's not a super
critical moment he goes for the right
choice which is great news but he needs
to keep control on the clock he also has
to make sure that after declining that
repetition he doesn't let it
psychologically affect him Knight E5
gets across it's a bad move does white
just simply continue with Bishop B2 or
are you seeing some tactics I think
possession Bishop D2 might be the
starting place and he plays it the queen
is forced to go back to C7 to keep
contact with the Knight but this is an
awkward situation for black so Bishop C3
is my first instinct and then C5 and
then Knight D6 and you can tell that all
of a sudden the pieces are coming to
play here and black does not have much
control this is a really good game thus
far from immunohanian yeah
a hundred percent and he continues the
momentum and that's the most important
thing Robert if amen can convert this
Advantage he's back in the match all you
need is one good win not a win that
comes out of luck not a win that comes
out of blunders but a win where you feel
that you outplayed your opponent yes and
it's what we keep saying and I know we
sound like a broken record but a
complete game is what's needed and
apparently that was a huge mistake so
suddenly Ohana has chances here is it
Bishop takes E5 and just grabbing a pawn
in the center uh that steals upon but it
does give black the bishop hair I like
the look of it uh maybe there's also
tons of potential I'm wondering if like
a queen E4 just to line up against this
Pawn on C6 and F4 becomes an option
there are too many pieces on the e-file
I like that I agree that white can pick
up the pawn but at the cost of that nice
C3 Bishop giving away the compensation
of a bishop Patty black it's something
that I I don't think it's super tempting
for white to go for after having a
dominating position Queen E4 on the
other hand was a move that I really like
the moment you pointed out Hanan makes
another Choice he first dilutes the
pressure on the queen side picks up the
extra Pawn the A2 Pawn is weak it's
snapped up immediately by gokish the C6
Pawn is hanging a lot of loose Bonds in
the position and he could start with the
move Rook to C6 as well
yeah and look at this Knight on D6 which
is pinned and under attack a couple
times so for black Rook A5 comes to mind
and was just played uh this queen is
under attack over here Rook takes C6
there's Queen takes C6 I think black
gets away with that uh because the queen
was threatened and he goes Queen B two
so Bishop V6 rooked I'm like did he just
blunder piece the answer is no he did
not uh he will take on C6 and get it
back but then there's Queen F7 Queen F2
oh
we might be seeing it after Rook C6 yes
you win the bishop back but black gets
the F2 Pawn it's happening on the board
I think Emin has lost control of the
position yeah as soon as he took on B6
on passant and opened up the queen side
for black it went from Google having no
no real moves no ideas just suddenly
some pieces that are getting out into
the open but the EVAP bar is still
hovering around the center uh Rook takes
D6 it is possible Queen takes F2 does
not lead to Checkmate so maybe that's
why it remains a bit balanced
a bit balanced but the worst is over for
good cash and again it comes down to
that dominating moment that he had where
he decided to liquidate the pieces and
the ponds and your suggestion of Queen
E4 I think that was really strong Robert
it keeps the tension on the board and
black doesn't have enough space to
actually get out of trouble but now
Queen B6 wow that is a move that we were
not expecting but an accurate find there
it hits the Rook on A5 it defends the
pawn on F2 the bishop on D6 is hanging
that's a great move by Amin yeah that's
great tactical awareness by him and you
would think well Queen is Loosely
defending this Pawn F2 so let me
distract the queen or give up The Rook
somehow that's not Checkmate so you can
give up this Pawn over here on F2 so
this Rook really is under attack that's
the main point and if you play Rook C5
that looks like a decent try I can take
on D6 give you the F2 pawn and at least
temporary rarely white would be up a
pawn in that position I think I mean you
know it's not a perfect game but I
really like the way he's playing his
game this feels like a true strong Blitz
game
a hundred percent and it's one of those
games where aiming from the start hasn't
been in trouble but he's the one who's
been driving the edge perhaps not the
most accurate but this is the format
this is Blitz chess and you can't expect
100 accuracy from the players but Robert
he just had such a nice Advantage out of
the opening and now I feel that again a
black has managed to stabilize I like
the idea of shutting down the defense
along the diagonal with placing a piece
on C5 he goes with the same idea in a
different way goes Bishop B4 deflects
the queen and look at that tactics
everywhere you can't take the Rook it's
a Checkmate on G2 if you pick up the
bishop there's a background Checkmate
yeah Bishop D5 Rook takes D5 Rook takes
her Queen F1 is made at the end but what
about Bishop D5 rook in a queen C4 can I
just pin your Rook how are you getting
out of that
oh that's nasty
55 Queen C4 what's the move here there's
a defense we see but maybe it's just
rook d8 and you say you can't pick it up
with The Rook as there's Queen F1 and
it's crazy completely if Rook d8 works
but I think it might wow I mean that or
Rook F5 this is crazy this looks like
black should be losing E4 for example
takes advantage of the pin but there's
Queen F3 check picking up this Rook over
here so it looks like it should be just
about winning for white and he puts Rook
F5 E4 hits look at that E4 would hit
both Rooks at the same time and yet it
doesn't work out because black has Rook
H5 going for checkmates ideas episode
wow and that's why Rook F5 is more
precise than Rook d8 because it allows
black to play Rook H5 and go in with the
mate on H2 Rook D6 after Rook H5 he
wants to give up the queen and get two
Rooks for the queen queen D5 is what
Emin wants he just landed he just
blooded the whole Rook Ohanian had 0.8
seconds when he made that move but
gukesh played too quickly and he just
resigns he doesn't even play to win on
time and a me and Ohio is on the board
you see the relief in his face he's on
the scoreboard after that good Game it
wasn't perfect as you were saying Tanya
but he got the job done at the very
least he was securing himself at Half
Point he gets a full one
it was a hundred percent Flow by Ohanian
and in the end with the pressure gukesh
crumbled king87 forgetting that The Rook
can be picked up all the attacks on the
board and Ohanian is back in the match
this is the kind of win that he needed
but he needs to keep the momentum going
because there's still a big three-point
deficit and Robert he's playing with the
black pieces he just needs to make sure
that things don't go out of control if
he can strike back one more time then
it's a real match then it's just
anyone's uh quarterfinals and this is a
funny move to get the uh brilliant
double exclamation points but black is
down a piece and giving up a rook in the
corner but the Knight on D2 was loose
this Pawn Z6 was under attack so this is
a highly theoretical line I have very
briefly looked at it in the past
um you know when I was been working with
some players just trying to go through
the complications here I don't really
remember what we looked at and it's
super complicated where this bishop is
trapped in the corner this Knight is
under attack Tanya these kind of
openings like these 20 move sequences
All the Rage these days and kukesh is
actually the one spending more time so
is that a good sign for Ohanian here
this is insane theory for anyone who's
not familiar with it but with all these
youngsters this new generation the next
generation of Jasper is that theoretical
knowledge is so on point they know
exactly what they're doing and that's
why the players have been blitzing it
out I think for both of them it's
familiar territory so far and now we see
Gucci advancing down the board with that
c Pawn it's not only a past Bond but it
really takes away squares from Black's
Bishop as well as the king with Rook D5
coming in next Robert yes he's going to
lose that Bishop on h8 the corner Bishop
but meanwhile the spawn on C7 The Rook
jumping on to B8 gives him enough
counter play and now it's Ohanian who's
in the think and I would be too facing
this position
yeah I hate variations like this where
if you make one mistake you just lose
and that's the type of opening this is
C7 Rook B8 is already a huge threat
trying to promote your Pawn so I think
if my memory serves me right this bishop
has to move I think to F5 and you're
trying to play Rook seed afterwards and
it's close it's a really close call here
but the bishop on h8 is imprisoned for
the long term and I think that's the
right way to play and it says white is
still slightly better in this position
but either side can go wrong
all right if Bishop F5 is the only move
to keep the balance because it comes out
with a temper of attacking that Rook on
B1 so white doesn't have the time to
push the C7 Pawn then it's a super
critical moment because if not Bishop F5
I'm also trying to find Alternatives
here and C7 Rook B8 is a massive title
for example if you develop the bishop
anywhere else Robert except F5 where it
hits the Rook white goes C7 black will
put the Rook on C8 I don't know if we
can just quickly show the difference of
what happens if black takes out the
bishop to the wrong Square it's so
important to come out with the tempo and
he finds it that's the good news but any
other move would allowed C7 Rook B8
picking up the D5 Pawn in time Rook C8
you go Rook B8 you pick up the D5 Pawn
next the other Rook jumps onto d8 and
it's game over
yeah so instead he does find Bishop F5
representing Rook C8 and you could see
Ohanian doing that chess player thing
like grabbing his like nose eye area
trying to recall the variations and he
recalls it well and now I think they're
at the end of their preparation like
they are still within the framework but
they're they've lost this specific moves
C7 allows King D7 that happened before
me did he pre-move King D7 because King
D7 was only legal after C7 so I'm not
sure if he pre-moved it but that move
happened very quickly and white had just
stole the A7 pawn and now black can take
on C7 but let's not forget that white is
up in exchange that Bishop on h8 is
trapped over on there but there's no way
to win it if you don't have a rook on
the board so Rook takes C7 seems like a
big mistake I think King C6 might be an
idea here because you're trying to go
King B6 and get that Rook out of there
and there's no Rook B1 because the
bishop controls the square
yeah so many tempting options and such
little time to
ask what this formats about
black can also be considering a move
like Bishop 86 trying to immediately
Target that Bishop on h8 but there are
drawbacks to that move because white
picks up the D5 Pawn with the check and
then lands with that Rook on d8
defending the bishop defending the day
it's very important I think for black to
make sure that you don't lose the D5
pawn and I'm just wondering
if there's time for black to go King C6
as well as the idea of going Bishop E6
and then Bishop to H6 I really want to
win that Bishop on h8 yeah me too and I
think that's what gukash will have to be
worried about but you see oh hanyan
going deep in the think tank trying to
make these ideas work eventually getting
the bishop and he does play King C6 with
King B6 to follow he's flushing The Rook
out of A7 Tanya if white isn't careful I
could see this going oh hanyan's way and
that is not what kukesh wants
he's definitely shaken up after what
just happened that was a one move
blunder but
blunders come out of cumulative pressure
in the position and that's what happened
to your case in that last game Rook C1
check played King B6 feels like the
natural response you want to push that
Rook out and wherever he goes it allows
black to step up with the bishop but
Robert it can be really tricky because
imagine King V6 here white falls back
all the way to A3
and the idea is to give a check from the
B line and then your king is in a big
Kill Zone you don't have time to pick up
the C7 Pawn because you end up losing
the Rook that's a great call and why he
went King to D6 I'm going to show that
quickly because it's super important the
king B6 Rook A3 you see the evil bar go
all the way up you can't take on C7
because Rook B3 check kicks the king
away from The Rook you lose the rook and
if you don't take that pawn then let's
say Play Bishop H6 Rook B3 check as you
were just pointing out that this king is
about to get checkmated over here like
that is a ladder Checkmate and you don't
have time to pick up the bishop in the
corner so white in fact would be winning
their great find by you Tanya and
there's a good find for amino hunting as
well he plays King to D6 he has Bishop
H6 next this bishop on h8 is still
trapped over here he's doing the right
thing he's playing this quite well at
the stage
absolutely it's such a fascinating
position right now with all these
tactical motives that exist and the
problem is if white goes back with the
Rook to D1 there's a slight difference
in the position because black king is
not on D7 it's on D6 the D5 Pawn is
defended so black can actually in fact
go Bishop 86 and start picking up
material already so Bishop 86 is in the
air and I'm just wondering if it's time
for
the case to start giving some lateral
checks Rook A6 comes to my mind
what do you do then do you hide with the
King to D7 yeah just go back here the
pawn is stopped but I maybe you can try
to go off the D5 Pawn because the
problem for black is you can never go E6
without letting the bishop out of its
cage so I'm wondering if you can go like
Rook A6 check and try to go Rook A5 to
get this Pawn on D5 uh that would allow
the king to go back and forth so it's
not completely the end of the world but
gukesh he's in for quite a big think
right now Tanya if you had to make a
prediction
results of this game based on the
position
thanks for just throwing me under the
bus there
I have product prediction but we do love
predictions I'm gonna make one I think
Robert we might be seeing a repetition
it might happen really soon or not my
prediction has just been thrown out of
the window I was expecting check and
back and forth and maybe that's what I
would have done just bailed out of this
crazy position but gokish is going for
it he says my one Pawn is on C7 the
other one is coming down the board but
Bishop H6 says black has two Bishops and
White's about to have none because it
hits the Rook on C1 so The Rook goes to
A1 but look at this the advantage is
turning in Black saver I don't see why
you can't just take this bishop this
part is completely stopped and there's a
deep on that can run up the board
this is getting crazy and completely out
of control you wanted a prediction draw
is not on the cards it's a game for two
results and that's either white wins or
black wins we see A5 it is an absolute
race Robert it's not about the two
Bishops it's about if black can create
some serious counter Chances with that
d-pawn but it looks so dangerous right
white just needs A6 rugby C7
how are you fighting these simple moves
I'm not sure because it is that quick
Bishop F4 so there's no Rook C1 so this
King can slide to C6 at some moment so
King C6
so he starts with A6 and your point is
that after King C6 if White's Rook is on
B7 you don't get A7 in because the Rook
will be hanging it's a good point maybe
Rook C8 there and oh he goes King C6
he's finding all these tough moves is
ohanyon and he's down under 10 seconds
right now plays Rook A8 which okay the
engine says not bad but it gets a
question mark but considering his 11
seconds I think it's a good decision
because if it's equal and it's in he's
on the easy side of the quality he'll
take that
is he threatening Drew k6 right now is
Rook A6 a threat on the board
it looks like it removing the guard of
this Rook on B7 and let's not forget the
bishop on F5 covers the C8 Square so I'm
wondering here if kukesh plays Rook B8
Rook takes Pawn takes Bishop takes and
then A7 and we see all these pieces come
off the board white will have a rook for
Bishop and two pawns he's going for it
but this d-pawn is going to be quite
advanced
I really doubt that white can be better
after the sequence of moves that you're
saying and that we are seeing happen on
the board yes white has that extra
exchange but black has got two pawns for
the exchange a very healthy Pawn
structure and Robert I think this one
Black's not in trouble
that's I think what I was getting at as
well it's one of these positions where
it says equal but how can black possibly
lose this game you'd have to blunder
horribly to lose and he can go back and
forth with King his King his King go to
F7 he has two Pawn D4 D3 H5 you can
never lose his position
uh did I say that draw is out of the
window I'm gonna take that back
well it looked like it shouldn't have
been a draw because it was a crazy
position now it does oh 1.8 seconds left
for black he needs to move quickly and
D2 coming up it had to be stopped and
the problem for gakesh is that he can't
dislodge that Bishop on F5 black just
keeps everything defunded three seconds
now it's just a one second increment
that the players get and I'm expecting
just the king to shuffle around there
isn't much that either of the players
can do to improve this possession
but look at how fast Ohanian is he had
0.8 seconds you know when he made one of
those moves now he works way back up to
six so he's going back and forth the
game is a draw and you know Ohana he
looks disappointed that's a good sign
you may be asking how could it be good
that he's disappointed because he
recognizes that he had chances like he
is feeling the flow of these games much
better than in the first few so I have
to say it's a different I mean Ohanian
after the break and for good cash he
still has a big lead he's still playing
fantastic chess but now he has an
opponent who is feeling of quite a bit
more confident and that happens right a
shaky start it takes a couple of rounds
to really understand and get into the
rhythm of things and it really does look
like Eminem has found his rhythm in the
in these last two games winning a
convincing game with the white pieces
and then holding his own with the black
pieces and now once again keeping it in
control on the clock he blitzes out the
opening moves Knight A4 there's a direct
threat on the queen and the idea is if
black gives a check on either A5 or B4
we'll see the Bishop from F4 falling
back and hitting that Queen with a tempo
yeah and then now you can take on C5 and
just get yourself the bishop pair I like
the start of this game for white I
really think that Ohanian is playing so
much better at gukesh a heavy favorite
regardless of the current score it is
plus three so that helps make him even
more of a favorite but I just really
like the way that Ohio has played in the
last few games and queen B5
how does this work Robert this works
because he's provoking white to go E3 a
move that many of us would make
immediately but the drawback of that
move is yes you gain a Tempo by hitting
that Queen but you blocked your own
Bishop from falling back to that D2
Square what we were highlighting earlier
after e3s when gakesh wants to give that
check on the diagonal and now there's no
good way to block the check so it's a
very tricky move there by gokish
provoking Ohana and to fall for this but
he's gonna find it and he's not gonna
play E3 what about E4 like that's the
other option because then if you give me
a check I can bring my Bishop back to
hit your queen it gets very spicy if I
were Ohan in here I'm just taking on C5
and after Bishop takes Knight takes
Queen takes it's even material but black
it has a pair of knights white has the
pair of Bishops right it's going to be a
bishop for a night trade so I think that
if I were Ohanian that's what I would be
aiming for I think I would just try to
liquidate a little bit and go for that
slight pull
but we've seen a hot end take decisions
which are Super direct and concrete you
imagine
I won't be surprised if we see and I
think after E4 point that the bishop can
fall back from F4 to D2 maybe what
gokish has in mind in response to E4 is
the simple advance from the C5 Pawn to
C4 you defend your C5 Pawn you want your
own Bishop to jump onto B4 and give a
check and seeing that as an issue
Ohanian does go with the idea of
simplifying but capturing the C5 Pawn
and I love gupcash's response Knight E4
played pretty instantly that attacks the
C5 Pawn so you could take with the
Knight Knight to B6 is out of the
question because Bishop takes C5 will
then hit the F2 Pawn with check mate not
just a little check over there that
would end the game and the Knight would
be lost on B6 so I really like this move
Knight E4 and you already see the
advantage start to go in Black's favor a
little bit I don't think it's huge but
black kids keep developing I wouldn't
take back on C5 right now there could be
issues down with this bishop on C8 if
you do
you mentioned spicy you want it spicy
this is sriracha level spicy Roxy one on
the board rabbit and black does need to
finish development I thought Knight C6
was such a natural move to make at that
moment you want to get the night into
the play but we see that it is indeed an
inaccuracy and this gives white an
opportunity to seize the initiative I'm
trying to think what's the move here
Robert
I'm trying to figure that as well I mean
E3 there's still Queen B4 check ideas
that can't be it so what is the move
Knight D4 this queen before check that
loses the game that's not gonna work so
I'm just gonna process of elimination
and none of these moves seem to work so
maybe it's just a simple move like
Knight to D2 that way you block the
check on the diagonal you try to get rid
of Black's best piece and then if black
takes on C5 with the Knight there could
be an E3 or an E4 strike openings Bishop
against the queen at the right moment
after first taking on C5 so I think that
things are getting oh I just as I was
about to pass it to you Tony I realized
that Knight D2 I don't think you can
even take on C5 because once these
trades happen there's a problem down the
ceiling I'm just going to show that it's
too much too many arrows that this looks
like an issue where you're losing a
piece for black
nicely spotted tactics there no chance
without us Knight D2 he finds it the
hardest moves in chess are retreating
moves this is a different MN Ohanian
from what we started with in the match
keeping up the accuracy but Robert he's
burnt the clock quite a bit he's now
under two minutes but it has been really
strong play by him he finds the tactics
with Knight D2 and once again trouble he
can't recapture the C5 Pawn Knight E4 in
the air white always wants to push the E
Pawn with a Tempo and now I'm struggling
to find a response for black that keeps
the balance maybe there's no balance
anymore
no it looks like white is just better
and he plays Bishop to B7 does good cash
he continues his development can you
just take this Knight on e4 D takes E4
but E3 always has this problem with
Queen before check that's the annoying
thing about this position is you know
what guest's plan is and now the bishop
on B7 defends the Knight on C6 so I
don't think the players know that black
has made some you know inaccuracy there
it just feels like a position and I'm
looking at the clock like you mentioned
Tanya two extra minutes for gukesh
Emma needs to find a way to finish his
developments with that two minute
deficit on the clock he needs to do that
quick as well and it's not really easy
once again E3 runs into pins along the
diagonal do you want to take the Knight
on e4 that would open up the d-line my
guess would be that's too dangerous to
play after Rook d8 coming in the Black
Knight jumping to D4 things could get
super tricky for white and I'm just
wondering if white has the time to make
moves like A3 B4 and I would never be
brave enough to play that on the board
because it just feels like I haven't
finished development I'm gonna end up
getting checkmated but is there a way
for black to seize the initiative if
white got slow here he starts with E3
on the board now he wants to go B4
oh my goodness Knight takes D2 then
before that's a great call by you
because Knight D2 Queen D2 that drops a
piece on A4 this queen is overloaded but
he wants to throw in B4 what a concept I
mean this is some fascinating chess I'm
just worried about ohanian's clock 41
seconds with your king in the center
it's only move 13. he has spent quite a
lot of time
is so sharp in tactics and that's one
thing that's been clear from the very
start finding these Dynamic ideas and
some Fearless play A3 really nicely
spotted it is a thematic idea in this
position to go a3b4 but nicely timed
there Knight D2 we're gonna see B4 on
the board and you can't pick up I was
gonna say Nike before but now white do
you pick up the D2 Knight or do you pick
up the B4 because Queen D2 runs into
Queen A4 so you
oh I'm not sure Robert do you go Queen
D2 or a B4
I I think Queen takes D2 because a B for
Queen B4 then if you take on D2 your
knight on A4 is still loose so I think
that Queen takes D2 at least makes
material equal but he's down to 15
seconds he's spending so much time here
and more than two and a half minutes on
the clock for gokish if I mean he's
played amazing chess but just really bad
time management there he picks it up
with the pawn the C5 Pawn is defended
white does have an extra Pawn but black
can strike after getting his King to
safety with the move A5 creating
weaknesses but he needs to make sure
that white doesn't have B5 there
yeah you look at this the queen C6 okay
clear threat is that really that big of
a threat you can just push upon E4 but
five seconds foreign he needs to move
more quickly and he plays Bishop E5
which was a very good move
objectively it's a position that's close
to a winning position he's got an extra
Pawn on the on the board but no time and
Robert it's it's going to be tough to
convert this with just two seconds on
the clock
it's actually equal material because the
Knight took that pawn on B4 uh earlier
so it's actually even but it's material
wise but not even because look at these
pawns here blacks pieces are restricted
white is playing an amazing game thus
far and look at how quickly he's playing
now B5 looks like a threat to push C6 H7
is hanging Ohanian is out playing gukesh
and in my head White had an extra Pawn
the last few moves and that's not even
true right now but yet he's got this big
advantage on the uh eval bar and Robert
as you're pointing out it is because of
the stronger Bishops and B5 the move
we've been talking about has been played
but at an inopportune moment he wants to
get C6 in dukesh says no way not
happening and is the C5 Pawn going to be
a liability for white now
great question it was such an asset now
it looks like it can be attacked and F4
look at how quickly 100 strikes he
doesn't have time to think and dukesh is
playing in ohanian's time travel but I
like the way he's handling this he's not
just playing every move instantly he's
spending a few seconds here and there
now he's sitting in for a thing because
F takes E5 is a threat Pawn to F5 is a
threat ef4 Queen F4 I don't like the
look of this Pawn in F6 in the open
diagonal so hanyon has made many good
ideas in this game but he just isn't
leaving himself with enough time
oh three and a half seconds left for
Emin Ohanian
and gukesh there goes into your thing
because it's a critical moment he needs
to decide what to do with the pawn face
off in the center and it's it's not an
easy choice to make if you sidestep with
your king white takes on E5 and it's
quite weak in the center
playing with fire he goes D4
everything's being traded off the bishop
on D3 is under big pin Robert do you
have time to go Queen D5 threatening a
mate on G2 as well as a bishop on D3
I think there's Queen H6 check and then
Bishop F1 type of ideas this is a wild
position and he plays Queenie five as a
blunder he created Bishop C4 he made it
with 1.7 seconds and he blundered he did
not have enough time was that Queen at
six Bishop C4 and was that the way to go
we saw that there was a big blunder we
will check it but with what Ohana played
he falls into the Trap loses a piece and
loses a game Robert what happened there
Queen D5 so tempting but apparently it
was losing on the spot
I'm gonna bring up the board let's get
this on the analysis board that in that
moment there he just did not leave
himself with enough time Queen D5 was a
huge blunder because of Queen H6 check
and if the King goes to jit Tanya your
point is well taken Bishop C4 actually
pins and wins the queen queen takes
before you flick in Rook takes d8 with
check and then you take this queen
you're gonna be up a queen for just two
minor pieces winning for white and if
you play it instead King to E8 so that
way you're not in a pin Bishop takes G6
check is a discovery and winning this
queen on D5 so Queen H6 check was step
one then you move the bishop somewhere
for step two and he would have seen this
if he just had more time you could see
he's red it's registering on his face he
knows he missed it and he's just not
leaving himself with enough time to
calculate
I think he's seeing it now Robert as we
can see on the camera and this is what
happened in game one as well
and we as chess players know just how
common this is you miss a win it's the
pressure of the situation the tension
just no seconds on the clock but that's
the format that's the brutality of it it
requires these best most talented
prodigies to give their best and we see
that Eminem once again struggling with
the clock and with playing on seconds
not being able to convert those
positions that was a big big Miss given
the math situation
yeah that would have cut the deficit to
two but now it is ballooned back to four
so I mean he needs to it's hard when
you're playing game after game and even
when I play casual Blitz Games if I lose
one I'm like oh gosh I should have had
that and you play Sorry another one but
you're still thinking about the last I
mean Ohio has chances in this match we
said that if he's within Striking
Distance heading into the bullet then he
can feel like he's really in this thing
but I right now he's playing a solid
game with the black pieces Tanya but I'm
worried about his clock he sells four
minutes plenty of time but every time he
sits in for a big think I'm wondering if
I'll last over a minute
I'm actually loving what because done
because this is one of my favorite
systems to play against the Queen's
Gambit Decline and against these
Carlsbad structures that black has for
those of you who might be new to chess
the carlsbot structure is when a black
has this A7 B7 C6 D5 upon uh sort of the
pawn chain in the middle of the board
and now very often the idea is here it's
a race to each other's King what white
wants to do is flick in G4 get the G
Pawn rolling that Knight on E5 stops
meanwhile the b-pawn from advancing down
the board you also want to combine some
strategic ideas Robert the attack on the
king side along with the Strategic
concept of the white king moving to B1
The Rook coming to C1 and really making
it difficult for black to advance on the
queen side to get some play against the
King this is one of my favorite lines
against the Queen's Gambit decline
I love this line and I actually love it
from both sides just because it's such a
fun position and C5 I was about to say
that's the correct strike and white says
good for you I'm gonna play G4 C takes
D4 e takes D4 we typically like open
files in front of the enemy King but
there's a knight in the way and you're
not going to dislodge it very easily on
the other hand white is going to play
Rook G1 and G5 and H4 and you know some
order and that's going to be a big
problem for this black king on G8
especially because it's Knight on E5 is
so powerful you need to kick that out of
there but you don't have a pawn moving
backwards to do so I do like it for
white despite the fact that the engine
says that black is even slightly better
yeah it's actually quite tricky because
usually we get these positions with the
other set of minor pieces still alive
white still has a dark Squad bishop and
black still has that Knight on C6 but
even with these trades it's super tricky
and a lot of fun because
whenever there's a race on the opposite
sides whenever there's opposite side
castling we can expect a fiery middle
game and G4 is exactly about that but
the trade of these two minor pieces that
I was talking about it does favor Black
the fact that the that white doesn't
have the dark Square Bishop it's good
news for black
yeah and this is not good news for black
because look at this Pawn go up to G5
and there's already Bishop H7 check the
king typically goes to h8 you can't do
that with F7 being loose so the king
will have to go to f8 and I'm guessing
that there's just a huge attack that can
only be stopped by an idea like Knight
to E4 so maybe hg5 fg594 because the G5
Pawn might be hanging with check in some
variations but I I don't see anything
else because if you move your knight
this way Bishop H7 check is going to be
a big problem
he's got a good idea for Knight D7 just
looks like calling for trouble Bishop 87
king f8 and you can even maybe sacrifice
that Knight on uh for the pawn on F7
open up the F line and that could just
result in a Checkmate immediately you
need to block the attack but after 94 I
I still see black struggling because
Robert you do win the G5 Pawn but for
white that means more open files on the
king side after Knight E4 a trade on e4
let's say Knight take C4 white picks up
the pawn on e4 with the bishop moves the
king and now the Rook coming on to G1
and it just looks after Bishop G5
King V1 it's trouble for black
yeah but you kind of have to go for this
and just play Bishop E6 give up this
Rook on A8 and then say my Bishops are
amazing in fact the engine says that
Black's not doing that badly there I was
sort of just finishing the variation but
this is clear that black has so much
control over this board with these great
Bishops so I'm looking at this as an
opportunity for Ohanian to get some
activity for material but I'm looking at
his clock and thinking that he is just
probably gonna lose this game because he
doesn't even have time to make his moves
yeah we saw that oh honey with head in
hand
shot
and for him to make a move
distressed in the position because
things are getting out of control he
decides to go Knight H5 and after a long
thing it is a big blunder Robert Bishop
87 give that Knight on F7 sack first
calculate later is the way to go in this
position
yeah this looks very straightforward
it's the brute force method and the
black king is in trouble this Knight
would also be lost in the event of the
king eventually taking on like Knight
takes her seven here also worse here in
Bishop G6 check just to pick up this
Knight but Bishop H7 first is clearly
more powerful because you're forcing the
king towards the center of the board so
for ohanyon I think he's a bit rattled
by that previous game and he he spent a
lot of time he's getting outplayed and
gukesh now he is correcting the match he
started well struggled for a couple
games and now he's just saying I am
going to crush you if I'm playing my
best chess
and he takes it slow and he says you
know what I've got all the tricks on the
board I'm first gonna defend the G5 Pawn
I think Knight F7 was also equally
strong looked super tempting but I like
this which is seconds on the clock Eman
will not survive this because Knight F7
is still coming up there are ideas you
could also go Rook F1 and start
threatening Checkmate in one with Rook
F7 just so many tempting options Robert
and the only problem for gokish is the
problem of plenty
it's true Rook F1 Bishop E6 Knight G6 is
made so this Knight G6 is the main
threat in addition to Rook takes F7
does go for Rook F1 it's just a check on
G5 picks up the piece with sidestep and
once again Rook F7 is made in one what
really surprises me is that Eman took
that long think and played the move
Knight H5
and that's not a good sign
and he resigns this game it's another
win for Gucci no that's not a good sign
at all and Tanya I feel like he lost the
flow that he had established in the
previous games where he was playing with
a good Pace he was playing these strong
moves but he's getting himself up to Too
Much Time trouble so this strategy needs
to change for ohanyon and it's a five
point margin now Robert with seven
points for gokish and Emin with just two
points and this is the last game of the
five minute with a one second increment
segment after this we will be moving on
to three plus one Robert if dukesh takes
this and goes on with a six point lead
that's gonna be too much to recover and
look at the position that we have on the
board and Amanda is shaking his head
yeah I think there's some kind of
Bishop B4 C3 Bishop a five nights he's I
don't know what's happening here this is
some weird Sicilian line
what do you make of eman's reaction here
did you see that he's laughing and he's
is he is he happy with his position is
he what's going on here
this reminds me of that game between
Magnus and Geary was it I don't know if
it was this exact position but it was
three pieces for a queen
um white isn't even better here I mean
look this kind of material right a queen
and one Pawn for three minor pieces uh
queen of one pawns Were Ten according to
the point value and the three minor
pieces about nine maybe I'm a little
more than nine depending on how that
they're valued I tend to like the minor
pieces especially in a position like
this where Black's King is very safe I
don't like this opening at all for white
all locations to do is
minor pieces that you're talking about
he's a bit slow
that white has or has to be enough time
to build that initiative with the queen
but I don't see it happening now with
Knight F6 the E4 Pawn is under Fire the
problem for gokish he can't just go shot
castle that Queen on D6 makes that
illegal so how do you get that Rook into
the game how do you find that Harmony in
your peace camp
yeah I was thinking Rook A5 to play
Bishop C5 but Rook A5 invites B4 and I'm
just sending White's pawns forward I
don't think I want that maybe bishop d8
to E7 and then I can I was about to say
I was about to say that same route and
it happens great call there Robin it is
you fall back to go forward and to push
your opponent's pieces back Bishop d8
Bishop B7 nice maneuver there yeah get
that Queen out of here let me Castle in
peace and for white I'd probably Castle
queenside I know The Bishop's coming to
E7 but maybe white can throw these pawns
forward uh it's the strategy that you
may want to employ instead he goes short
Castle he wants a more solid position
well now you can go shark Castle as well
defend that G7 pawn and the problem of
The Rook has been solved and now it's
just going to be slow game uh by gokish
getting his pieces into play he can
start thinking about moves like D6
trying to get the bishop out Knight will
come to E5 hit that Bishop on C4 uh
Robert in these kind of positions
usually the minor pieces are eventually
stronger than the queen and the
evaluation bar is completely irrelevant
I think black wins this type of position
at like a very high rate at the highest
levels because white has no plan like
black can just like as you said D6
Bishop D7 great Rook A5 a rook lift that
looks good uh you can pretty much do
whatever you want with black because you
have more pieces you have three minor
pieces for a queen and I don't see any
aggressive intentions for white uh this
looks like it's going to be a tough game
for amino hanyan
and in this kind of a material imbalance
it only works out for the queen if the
queen and the Rooks can combine to
create an attack on the white on the
black king you need open files for that
you need more open a more open position
for that and it's hard to imagine black
having any weaknesses around the king
the queen giving any counter checks in
this position and with none of that
possible the three minor pieces
eventually do end up prevailing but of
course the bar is still Level it's far
from that uh but again Robert I hate to
point this out in every single game but
you know exactly what I'm about to say
look at that clock all right so you're
gonna say look at kukash's trophy case
because you know you mentioned that as
much as I've said no I knew what you
were gonna say and I feel like um for
Ohan he will be faster in the three
minute portion that tends to happen for
some players where they play quite
slowly with the most amount of time and
then suddenly they're super fast and
they don't need to think anymore but
this is just a bad position for white
and I'm trying to think of plans because
I saw that question from a longing cat I
think was the featured Chatter's name
but what plans could white have maybe
Rook to D1 and after D6 take on D6 that
comes to mind because I just want to
eliminate some of Black's material
there's so many minor pieces but that
should still be really good for good
cash so look at the clock look at the
position
I mean Tanya
I feel like resigning is white because I
don't actually know what plan to play
and look at yogesha's trophies well
finally I mean does take the decision to
go with E5 the Knight jumps onto H5
hitting the Queen the queen has to fall
back stay connected to that E5 Pawn keep
it defended
black just has to be a little careful
with that Knight on H5 you could go
Knight F4 get it back to G6 you were
asking for a plan and I think what Emin
wants with this is to try to set up a
battery along the b187 diagonal Bishop
D3 Queen E4 when you're playing with the
queen against three minor pieces you
really want to try to find ways to build
an attack against the black king and
that could be an idea that comes to mind
but Robert again Eman just seems to take
so much time for these moments which
honestly a move like Rook D1 would be
would be good enough and you can play it
in seconds but you just end up burning
so much of your clock and your problems
are still on the board yeah perfect is
the enemy of the good and as Hikaru
likes to say it's best to play a good
move quickly rather than the perfect
move slowly in the quickest of time
control so I'm looking at this position
it's not like white is lost it's not
like black has a knockout at least not
yet and I think A4 is a good move
because if we think advantages in the
position white has three on one on the
queen side so if you can get those pawns
rolling that could be beneficial for
white and black needs to complete the
development but Bishop D7 may walk into
a timely Rook D1 there are many pieces
in the D file so there are chances here
for immune
I like what you're saying right now
because for
bloody is good as they can find that
harmony with each other and right now
with the Rooks not being connected not
easy to get Bishop D7 in it's a bit of a
big ask Knight jumps onto F4 a nice move
there but white does have the option to
start attacking the minor pieces instead
he goes on with the plan of gaining more
space on the Queen's side and continues
with the pawn storm I think it's a good
call because uh right now the bishop on
C7 has lost some of its scope it can't
get onto this diagonal towards the white
king Bishop D7 played and look at the
eval bar suddenly creeping up in White's
favor I wonder why I guess g3 at the
right moment will kick this Knight back
then F4 why is gaining a lot of space
here Tanya and this bishop on D7 that's
the most restricted piece for black it's
not doing much of anything
and that's the key word here what you
said restricted why would they spawn
advances as we can see controls more
squares on the board which means less
activity for the minor pieces G3 f4 on
the king side will have a similar effect
really taking away key squares from the
knights and the Bishops blocking down
the diagonals also making sure that the
Black Knight Can't Jump Around the other
plan that we were talking about a
potential battery on the b187 diagonal
is also being hinted at watch out for a
timely B5 the queen from E4 is a
multi-purpose piece it's eyeing that B7
Pawn in certain positions and a hunting
is playing perfectly since I said that I
had no idea what to do as white is
showing me the answer he's playing
really well right now and he needs to
play F4 he does so I think he could have
played the move more quickly if he were
playing bullet he would have played F4
as a borderline pre-move so he is
playing great at the moment and I'm
already looking at tactics at some point
on these diagonal blacks backing up over
here and I mean goes forward and
apparently that was not the right move
I'm not a fan of that because that
Bishop either on C4 or on D3 just felt
so much stronger this allows black again
we've been talking about bringing those
minor pieces together it looks like
dukesh has managed to do that Knight C3
was a big threat the pawn had to be
defended a basic bit of threat that had
to be parried Rook C1 played
and now the problem for White is you
can't get C4 in because B4 is hanging so
what is White's next move here F5 is the
dream but it leaves weak squares behind
oh wow H4 I wasn't expecting that Robert
no I'm not sure what he's going for on
that side of the board Knight F6 watch
out for Knight G4 and H5 has become
available yeah white has too many
weaknesses now you left a lot of squares
behind
yeah I don't know what H4 was about but
this just means the Knight jumps onto G4
and always watch out for that Rook d8
landing on that D2 Square the Bishop
from A7 nicely placed this is looking
super dangerous for white black could
also reroute the bishop to D7 start
threatening some checks along the
diagonal oh that could be a really good
idea another idea that comes on is
Knight D4 if you want to try to take
White's Bishop on A4 over here but there
are many options for black Bishop D7 E5
looks really good as you recommended
Knight G4 it's hard to complain about
putting in G4 but he does go for the
simplification the engine is not
thrilled by it but Tanya I'm looking at
this position and is white in time with
these Queen side passers
wow and that's the big question right
now because the bishop on A4 could also
end up trapped in certain positions uh
gukesh rightly picks up the D4 Pawn
before white gets the beep on all the
way down to the board but the pieces are
loose can white find a way to actually
win one of the minor pieces
yes we're talking about how white was in
trouble uh those minor pieces were
thriving now the minor pieces are
discombobulated they're all over the
place I still think that this Knight G4
is going to be scary at some moment but
Bishop A7 is meant by B6 and now the
pawns are really storming forward and
Bishop C5 walks into pins where your
Rook on C8 is in trouble so not an easy
moment for kukesh who's dropped himself
down to 45 seconds
under
10 seconds on the clock and this is the
kind of position where blunders are so
easy to just lose a piece and look at
this he goes for the pawn Advance on A6
trying to create a diversion but this
just allows a lot of checks things are
getting out of hand here the Knight
would love to jump to G4 but the bishop
on D7 is hanging he first hits The Rook
The Rook hits the queen hits the pawn on
G3 and I think this might be game over
firemen so he gives up the queen he
wants some kind of Rook C1 but Rook c1's
Bishop B7 check and then take on a seven
three minor pieces is too much for a
rook
and we see that happen and he gets
flagged the king moves Bishop A7 and
that would be game over dukesh finishes
the five plus one with a six point lead
it's eight to two Robert and that is the
end of the five plus one segment and we
see gokish there with his trophies
looking confident and he's showing why
he is one of the best in the world he's
barely reacting because he is looking
over that game he is analyzing he's
trying to look through the opening stage
was that really good for me out of the
opening yes it was there's a really nice
game
from good cash overall there were some
moments where White had chances but I
thought that throughout that one
so you can be go speechless almost I
thought gukesh played a very nice game
a really nice game showing how to handle
these material imbalances in the game
he's on fire right now we are heading
into three plus one things are gonna get
even more exciting more blunders more
brilliances coming up we'll be back in
just a few
thank you
this right here is how I use chessable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I've
actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jacksonville came around when I got on
adjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're gonna be folders now so
I can categorize my white black and all
tactics in-game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like this
so they're like how many testable books
you got I'm like all of them how are you
accessible is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
trustable it's actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 and bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just worth
just being honest with you
[Music]
it's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
and compete by voting for your predicted
results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we are about to go into the three plus
one segment of the junior speed Chess
Championship quarterfinal it's a single
elimination bracket and dukesh is making
it a look like a blowout match so far
Robert it's age to two is the score and
the 17 year old Indian has been on fire
from the start
absolute Superstar is good cash you see
his list of accomplishments there's just
a few of the many he recently scored
third place in Norway chess he didn't
lose a single game in classical against
the world's Elite including Magnus
Carlson and Kara Nakamura five gonna car
one and the rest of the budge so he is I
was gonna say a man on a mission but
he's still kind of a kid he's in the
junior speed Chess Championship but he's
an absolute Beast
kid what kid Robert he's world number
13. I know he's 17 but we've seen him
play against the best players in the
world and hold his own he just recently
beat a Magnus on his 17th birthday uh he
is the youngest player to have ever
beaten the former world champion as
we're still struggling to say that but
right now it is about his match against
Emin and for kakish the junior speed
Championship means a lot because if he
wins it Robert it's his ticket to the
speed Chess Championship with the big
boys and he played in the speeches
championship last year he would like to
earn that ticket directly doesn't want
to wait on the invitation game will I
get it maybe not yeah you probably will
I'm guessing but still he wants to earn
it directly by winning the junior speed
test championship and he's off to a
great start against emilohan in the
eight seed
a fantastic start because take a look at
that we are through with the five minute
with a one second increment and that
segment ends with gaucasian eight points
Emma Ohana with two points there the
strategy for Emin Robert here has to be
the three plus one he needs to make sure
that he takes that segment with at least
a point or two because the one plus one
again it's anyone's battle it's anyone's
game it's absolute Randomness and even
the best player on paper struggles in
those format but today this man is not
struggling meanwhile Emin who has had
difficult position the clock as well has
been tricky for him from the start the
three plus one Robin what's your
prediction will we see Eman handle the
clock better this time yes I think he
will there's something a bit
uncomfortable for players and the five
minute time Patrol because they don't
play it ever top players do not play
with five minutes on the clock to start
with it's just not a Time control
they're used to in fide over the board
tournaments it's three minutes plus two
second increment online and title
Tuesday which is gonna start in about
half an hour it's three minute plus one
second increment which is the time
control we're seeing right now so that
five minute timer was a bit
uncomfortable for top players and I I
want to add it almost always favors the
stronger player and gukesh is much
higher rated than his opponent
yes on paper a big a hard favorite
gaucasian this one starts with the white
piece of the three minute segment and it
is a ragazin out of the opening and we
see the players are blitzing out their
moves so so far so good on the clock for
MN uh gukesh hits that Bishop forces
black to take the Knight on C3 because
the B7 Pawn was hanging it means a
bishop pair for white with blacks
knights in these positions are often
Relentless as well once the queen moves
the Knight can jump to E4 and find its
own activity yeah and I one additional
point about the time management is when
you're playing someone like gukesh
you're like I can't afford to make a
mistake when they're five minutes in the
clock when they're three minutes on the
clock a minute plays in these title
Tuesdays in these events he understands
that these top players they do make
mistakes they're they're Human After All
and he brings that Knight to E4 he's
doing everything right thus far you
could ask for more from the black side
but B5 is gonna hit him at some point he
needs to be ready for it
and this is called a minority attack in
chess and it's such a great plan to be
aware of Robert when you've got less
number of Pawns than your opponent on a
certain side in this case the queen side
you are actually the one who advanced on
the board with those pawns trying to
create weaknesses the dream for white
here is to get a successful B5 it will
lead black with a potential weak alone
isolated Pawn on the queen side it's a
very thematic approach I like it and
that's what Eman is fighting against
lining up that Rook against the queen so
B5 right now is out of the question but
it's always in the air yes it's White's
main idea in these positions the Knight
comes back to D7 is B5 available because
of C takes there's Queen takes C8 check
it's a difficult evaluation there
assessing it does it very quickly as
soon as I said it was challenging he
said yeah not for me maybe for you
Robert but not this 27 44 in the live
ratings and Tanya I have to say I like
White's position
I get what you're saying and I would
have to agree with you here Robert I
generally like agreeing with you but
here especially because white also has
the bishop pair and we've been talking
about the aim of the minority attack and
we can imagine once white gets a trade
in on C6 whenever he decides to do that
when black recaptures if black
recaptures with the pawn the pawn on C6
is weak if you capture with the Rook the
pawn on B7 is weak this is a model game
on how to go about getting a minority
attack in and look at the time
management I mean Gucci is just blitzing
out his moves and he's playing
excellently it's a model game a pawn
chain is only as strong as this base
Pawn right now the base Pawn is on B7
but that pawn chain is about to shrink
to C6 so it sticks out more easier for
white to attack with the open lines and
I'm looking at the clock I'm looking at
the Bishops I love this for gookish
and I'm looking at White's queen that
Queen lands on A7 you're hitting that
base of the pawn chain that you're
talking about Queen A7 I don't even see
a good way for black to actually defend
that B7 Pawn it's a big threat on the
board and Emin needs to find a way to be
able to meet the attack on the B7 Pawn
Robert the C6 Pawn is pinned this is big
trouble for black spawns on the queen
side it is and this bishop on e4 looks
very strong but it belongs on D7 it
belongs protecting the pawn on C6
sometimes you have to suffer with
passive defense but that Bishop on e4
has a hard time getting back it looks
like you're going for G2 good luck
bringing another piece into the attack
and he plays C5 a bit of desperation a
quick Queen A7 I mean go cash does this
guy think the answer is yes he just
thinks so quickly and he's such a strong
player that he can make those moves in
one second
and this is what I was talking about
right once the queen gets to A7 it's
going to be a nightmare to try and
defend those pawns on the queen side
currently it's Black's Knight who's
doing that but it is going to be tricky
for black to hold this position Queen C6
a nice Queen off Queen trade offer you
can't really take it because that pawn
on C6 will be a monster that will go
down the boat to C7 and eventually to
see it is this already game over for
black you know he's hanging in there
he's hanging in tough is amino hanging
but he's down over two minutes on the
clock but suddenly it says that black
had a slight Advantage why in the world
was that
wow and just six seconds he loses the C4
Pawn the d-pawn is about to March down
the board Robert I do not see a way for
black to penetrate to create threats
against White's King you're down upon
your knight is more passive than the
bishop I asked you if this is busted and
I think now it is it's completely busted
uh this Pawn on B6 is likely to drop in
the next few moves and guest is thinking
at this moment because he has a winning
position he doesn't need to win on the
clock anymore he can just end the game
in a few moves uh with best play but
Rook C8 okay suddenly we're seeing at
least some semblance of threats wow
do you see that move Rook C7 you see the
response to that move
[Laughter]
oh he blundered me that was a sick fight
from gookash
Robert I think we need to do a little
bit of an action replay there of what
just happened because Rook C7 was a star
move yeah let's bring up an analysis for
it because that move Rook C7 came out of
nowhere I thought he had to move the
queen to make sure that that Rook wasn't
getting in but he plays Rook C7 because
the Knight is pinned so if Rook C7
Bishop C7 well good luck stopping this
b-pawn that was an amazing find by
gukesh giving up his Rook to win a queen
and though black London
here down the board and it was a game
over and with this kakesh takes the
first game of the three minutes plus one
and it's already a crazy opening in the
second one Robert black I'm gonna try
and do the math here it's taking me a
while but it turns out that the material
is even the material is even but
apparently the position is not
completely even and it trades on e4 and
brings his Rook to see it he wants that
C5 Pawn a bishop B7 that's that's not
gonna work out here sometimes you get
that in in end games specifically but
not with the Queens on the board it's
not going to end well for white so C5 is
just dropping in this position Tanya and
well black will be up a pawn
it's looking very tricky because
visually it feels that black with those
double e pawns there should be
compensation for white as well and one
of them has been picked up Black's King
is still in the center the evaluar gives
an advantage to black but I think
practically it's not so easy to
understand that we've got the luxury of
being able to see that but for the
players Robert his King is still in the
center he's got to make sure that he
keeps attacking the pieces which he's
doing the C2 Pawn is hanging the bishop
doesn't have too many squares Bishop A6
runs into Rook C6 oh
oh my gosh so what this is trouble does
white have Queen takes A6 maybe that
saves your Bishop but Rook takes C2
still looks like a problem down here I
don't like this at all and I agree with
that uh chat from I think it was Krishna
one two three four something like that
it was a good feature chat there saying
that yes ahanyan has experience but time
management momentum all against him at
this point where he may be beating
Grandmasters strong Grand Masters in
title Tuesday but he's played this whole
match and he has to enter this time
Patrol down by six points and now it's
up to seven this match is not going the
way oh honey would have dreamed of
wow and gakesh has been Relentless
taking advantage of the clock as well as
showing speed in moves that are actually
objectively good so he's definitely a
player in farm today and I think that's
going to be a tough task for Emin to
come back from Bishop E4 we see that's a
cross on the board and gakesh slows down
he smells it as well and the reason for
that is when your opponent's king is
still in the center unexposed as the
white King on E1 is there's a feeling
that you need to do something quick to
take advantage of that and he does it
look at that Moon Knight E5 it cuts off
the queen from defending the bishop on
e4 white doesn't have the time to go
shot Castle you can't really capture the
Knight on E5 because the Rook will pick
up that Knight and there is too much on
the line on the e-file you end up losing
big big material Robert Knight E5 it
might just be time to throw in the towel
I'm trying to find what's the way that
white actually keeps the material going
here maybe Knight G5 it's an awkward
move but you are protecting your Bishop
on e4 and threatening nothing because
the 95 also covers F7 so I'm not seeing
too many options here for white that
don't lose material and I think Knight
G5 would be the only thing that comes to
mind for me
I agree with you because if you move the
bishop anywhere trying to defend your
Bishop white can get black and get rid
of the white key Defender the Knight on
F3 and then jump in with the Rook to E5
so for example a move like Bishop
there's no good square but anyway boy
does find another way he goes Queen A6
and gokish immediately goes with shot
Castle doesn't even consider taking on
e4 look at that tactical awareness
rabbit 94 would have run into Queen a
check recapturing that Knight on e4 and
gokish in seconds doesn't even blink an
eye just got shot Castle all the threats
on the board and white skiing in the
center is about to be mated except the
C1 Bishop I say this in the most
devastating respectful way possible as
good cash wins another game I'm scared
of him like what I'm seeing right now is
scary like he is just obliterating a
very strong opponent right now and he's
making it look easy he stumbled a little
bit in the five plus one when a honey
won that first game he started sensing
that things were shifting a little bit
in Ohio's favor and then go cash like
you know I'm a professional you may get
a game you may get two games but I'm
going to stop the bleeding and I'm going
to then take over the initiative this
has been a fantastic match from gukesh
he is a superstar I've said it enough
times today but it's true he is so darn
strong I don't know how anyone in the
junior speeches Championship is going to
compete with him and there are some
fantastic players but when he's in this
form I just don't know what you can do
okay she's a huge favorite not just in
this match Robert but in the entire
Junior speed Chess Championship this
year he is the top seed of the event
and one can understand that he is well
number 13 he's almost 27.50 at this age
he's had phenomenal performances but of
course with the speed Chess Championship
it is an unpredictable format cookies is
a big favorite the last three speech
Junior speech has championships has been
won by an Indian and Robert it might be
the fourth one as well
Arjun Lucas yup not bad names on that
list they're all well I guess Neo
technically isn't a super Grand Master
but you know the top players they
consider him just like the rest of them
are super duper strong and speaking of
super strong this attack that white is
building on the king side it looks like
that's going to be super powerful
because H4 played there could be G5 and
F5 and Knight coming to E5 at the right
moment where is Black's attack Queen
does come up to A5 maybe trying to eye
some B4 and B3 stuff opening up that
flank but it does appear that white is
just pressing forward and is unfazed
about the business in the queen side
although he should have been perhaps
foreign
all the way down Queen C6 it hits the
Rook on it but it is a bad move Robert
I'm just wondering is that some crazy
stuff like A3 on the board yeah now you
just break it all open this this looks
like a checkmating attack so I picked
the wrong time to compliment good care
so much because he immediately uh plays
a bit of a howler of a game he is busted
right now this is just a huge attack
he might lose this game but there's no
such thing as a wrong time to compliment
so that's absolutely fine but this
attack it does seem like Black's getting
to the white king first you don't want
to ever play the movie A2 check it's
only a check and then white steps to
onto A1 and that pawn on A2 is White's
best friend it guards the king it's
exactly what black doesn't want black
wants to get rid of that bot and I'm
just wondering here if white if black
was to take on B2 white must recapture
that pawn on it on V2 and after Queen A2
check that's okay want to think about
stepping up with the King to C3 I mean
to me it just looks completely lost no
it's not gonna I actually think that
after a takes B2 there might be Queen A4
which could save the day because if you
trade the Queens the attack isn't very
strong or it might still be there but
it's not going to be as uh menacing but
if you move the queen away somewhere
then you lose the Rook on Aid so I
actually think that oh honey has paused
the right moment but he plays ab2 anyway
and the advantage is gone
wow and that's the problem Robert
against guys like gokish getting a
winning position is sometimes not even
half the job done
no because the hardest game to win is a
winning position and look at this now
it's white with the upper hand up a pawn
over there on the king side this D5 Pawn
is weak Rook A1 next to trade pieces off
and kukesh is up look at the clock he's
up nearly two minutes
and look at the position he's up a pawn
with all the
all of my Pawn is super weak in the
position what a turnaround this has been
but Robert in my head I'm still trying
to think what it what did Eman miss that
because the attack looked so powerful
yeah Queen A4 I just a retreating move
not always easy to spot those and I
don't know what the winning or the great
continuation was winning is strong and
we sometimes see the bar and it's like
minus three or plus three that doesn't
mean it's easy and the players are just
going to accomplish it this position wow
King of the Hill he wins that game but
he's playing chess so is that King safe
that's a big question but what I was
gonna say is this position looks a lot
better right you see the eval bar quite
High yeah white looks like he should win
this position but the other one was so
complicated hard to find the accurate
continuation
and that King is only safe because of
all the knights on the board black can
give a check on E2 but then the other
night from D5 comes back to E3 and just
look how beautifully they actually
defend the position of that white king
and now Rook F2 it does walk into a
check winning a piece and what Eman has
in mind is that with that King shift
that you were pointing out both the
knights would be attacked and that's the
Trap but it still feels like 97 should
be the correct move and I'm trying to
find a follow-up Maybe
97 can get fit
Robert do you see a move there I'm just
waiting for Gucci maybe Knight she's six
oh I love it it's gonna show us the way
no that's great knight G6 was awesome
and this wasn't it whoa Rook D3 but he
could have taken the Knight on E7
white is currently a piece up both
nights are attacked right now he goes
Knight F5 default Pawn isn't hanging
anymore so he goes into this end game
with an extra piece and the other Rook
will come onto the open file start
threatening a Checkmate in one
it's happening Rook A1 Rook 8 The Rook
on D2 the Knight on D7 are absolutely
hopeless against this attack tries to
hide on it seven
can you even just take on H6 and just
say I win a pawn and he goes for that
variation apparently not the absolute
best but still should be good enough
I think it's a super practical approach
you've got an extra Pawn you do it you
do the job the Deep on will get the job
done the Knight currently is attacked on
F5 he goes to D7 eyeing that F7 Pawn as
well
King C4 making sure you stay connected
to the d-pawn I think the d-pawn is the
one that will decide the game picks up
another pawn and Robert rukichit looks
like a checkmate
it looks like one it smells like one it
is one that is check and made and it's
another victory for gukesh and for amino
hanyan he's probably super frustrated at
this stage and look what good cash is
doing he's playing Blitz openings you
won't see who cash play like this in
classical tournaments no no no these are
reserved for Blitz Games and as a player
who plays the hippo online I have to say
googesh has good style in his openings I
play this a lot from the black side so I
like it
and I see that evalubar also likes it
for black but it's so scary to face as
well I think it's a great choice by Emin
given the math situation he needs to go
absolutely wild and absolutely crazy
create a chance in every possible game
it might not go well but it's the need
of the match right now Robin what's been
really impressive for me has also been
have you noticed Caucasian camera he's
had no expression so far he's just been
Relentless in his place scoring win
after win
and absolutely just sitting there cool
and calm and composed that's a sign of a
champion
I would probably be doing like a little
dance right now with that kind of a
margin on the board very mature approach
from he just stole a Central Pawn and I
saw that Amin was once again flustered
very upset with how this match is going
and some may say it's great experience
but when you're in the match you're just
mad because you're a fantastic chess
player so when you're losing games
you're like I can do this what's wrong
why am I not you know getting these
points he blundered a Central Pawn that
doesn't happen to minohanyan very often
it's just the good cash effect he's just
playing Super well as you said he's
unphased and
he's just a beast like I know aliban
might be mad at me for uh you know some
infringements he might get sued by ADI
bond for calling someone else the beast
but gukesh is an absolute monster
yeah he's playing like one today he has
been playing like one for quite a while
now and Robin I still try to get my head
around the fact that he's just 17. he
turns 17 a couple of weeks ago and
that's insane he's already in the world
top 15 one of the best players in the
world and we can see his attitude he's
up by age to two has just won the last
game and he stays completely calm and
composed and that with the black pieces
I think he's got a good position out of
the opening as well that night on e4
there's no Pawn that can get to it you
can't really get rid of it it's a strong
night and never forget the G file which
is open can eventually be used by black
to start targeting the G2 Pawn I will
never forget that you told me not to I
will never ever forget that I I like to
move Knight G5 it's a great move just
getting the Knight out of the center
putting pressure down the G file on the
G2 eventually if you take Pawn takes
back the Knight is kicked out of f4
which means H5 is dropping he said
brings his Knight back to D2 and for
gookesh maybe it's time to play Rook
gape instead he plays E5 and Strikes in
the center
but that's
a little move to make is you not only
open yourself to the F5 point but also
the D line where the Rook is extraing
the queen but because you have to Bishop
F5 slows down he has to move the queen
he has to find the right Square for the
queen and I'm just wondering what square
is that you don't want to move it to the
E file Robert because white already has
a rook on E1 that doesn't look ideal do
you want to perhaps go Queen C6 trying
to provoke the move D5 he says I don't
care about the Rook on E1 I'm gonna come
back with the queen to eat it yeah for
the first time today probably I'm a
little disappointed I'm gonna go back
let's bring up the analysis board
because I wanted to go cash to sacrifice
his Queen and he's already had a game
where he had three minor pieces for the
queen at this moment if you take on F4
Bishop D7 Pawn takes E3 you're getting a
third minor piece for the queen and
you're completely winning like this was
just one by one take six takes and you
get all the pieces you want for the
queen so you know I know maybe could
cash the first time it was stressful
logical logical but here I just thought
that he could just grab all the miners
and he is still much better he's has a
great position but it just feels like
this is a little bit more challenging
than it could have been a though I look
at the position now and say all right
good guess you're right again you're
making my commentary obviously I just
don't have anything to talk about
because all your moves are so good
same level of accuracy and the speed
with which it's played I mean look at
the domination that black has going on
currently white trying to create Chaos
on the board instead of falling back
with the bishop goes Bishop to F2 so he
wants to pick up the Knight on G3 and
I'm just wondering in blackcoe 94 in
this position
looks like it's kind of tricky 94 Bishop
F5 I was thinking of Rook D3 Robert and
tactics tactics tactics
wow take on D3 to get this F2 Bishop
looks possible I'm wondering you know
which Knight to bring the E4 as well
because you can bring your G3 Knight you
can also bring your g59 and FG Bishop G3
all right white staring into the center
some weaknesses in Black's Camp so there
is quite a bit for gukesh to figure out
and look at the clock by the way they're
both about to be at 40 seconds
I like with the first time that we're
seeing gukesh and Emin in this match
have the exact same time he goes for 94
he chooses the Knight that keeps uh the
other night from G3 to E4 and drop it
Rook D3 was the idea that I had in mind
is that working because a lot of pieces
are hanging the E4 Knight can also be
picked up yukesh has calculated it
through he chooses the right approach
Knight D2 and where's the killer blow he
goes Rook at fate but Rook 63 definitely
look like a good try he instead goes for
this because white has some loose pieces
where's this bishop going you might have
to play G4 but then Knight F3 is a fork
against these Rooks on D2 and E1 uh this
is bad news once again foreign it's been
that kind of day it's been a dominant
display from gookesh but for hanyan is
just struggle after struggle
oh wow
about a dozen a rule but now they're
playing on seconds
sidestep with the Queen White wants to
get the C6 Pawn rolling how is he
playing like this gkesh is just
unbelievable
yeah he wants some kind of queen G6 94
these Bishops are both loose he starts
with Knight E4 because the bishop 102 is
already hanging and you can't take
enough too because of Queen takes so
watch out there are some pins here but
Queen G6 the king and B1 the bishop on
G4 the bishop on F2
don't forget
never forget I have not forgotten don't
you worry although maybe I should forget
because all those pieces that we're just
talking about are gone uh but Bishop D4
another nice move make sure the Knight
is 93.
wait whoa what's is this like a mate if
you get Queen A4 here's Queen G1 and
that's game
you're up to Pieces all you had to do
was probably the thread and look at Evan
you see him reacting he missed Queen G1
which keeps everything intact and the
nightmare continues there and gokish
with a smile on his face for the first
time I wonder why I think it's because I
mean oh honey put A5 on his first move
it's what you call tilt and I have you
have to feel for him I mean there's no
way around it this has been a demolition
gukash has played Stellar chess that
doesn't mean that Amino hunting is not
fantastic that you know he won't have a
great career ahead of him but at the at
this moment in time uh gukesh is the
stronger player and he's showing that to
the world right now
yeah this is very difficult for Emin
also psychologically you're at this
stage where you're almost giving up at
this point you know it yourself how
difficult it is to come back into the
into the match but you know that you
have to
sort of bear it for a while longer you
know you want the pain to stop Robert at
this point but there's no stopping it
oh that that may be sad kind of the way
you just framed that you know I do want
the pain to stop I don't want anybody to
hurt but what gukesh is doing
you know yeah he's laying down the hurt
right now I mean just everything he's
doing is super powerful look at this
game he gave upon brought his Knight to
G5 he can put his Queen out to H5 if he
wants black has not developed any of
these pieces because his first move was
A5
yeah and that Queen on 86 is not gonna
allow the black king to Castle black is
forced to create more dark Square
weaknesses along on the king's side and
even if you get Bishop G7 you have to
make more pawn moves because the 87 spot
was tender white meanwhile has finished
development has placed all his pieces
ready for the attack and gokish is
already wondering if he can start
marching down the board with the F Pawn
you can go F4 before you bring your
knight back trying to create play when
black decides to go shark castle with
the King right this nightmare G5 not
actually under attack at the moment
because the Rook is loose but somehow I
feel like black is doing quite okay
black is very solid and I've oh I say
that and then is there Knight F7 is that
the point
Knight F7 is definitely on gokisha's
radar and the big question is can
scandal up with it can he find the
follow-up to it I am
you mention it as commentators we'd love
to see that happen on the board and
there it is gokish playing to the crowd
and it's also the accurate move he also
finds the follow-up Robert a quiet move
Queen T4 putting the pressure on G6 and
Eman is a laughing
through the pain yeah because if you
don't laugh you cry and this move is
phenomenal G5 there's F4 uh ideas we
just blast open this King side and this
king is just being hunted so great fine
night sacrifice follow up by Queen to G4
and you can't protect G6 in any good way
it's another knockout
this is amazing Knight F7 Queen G4 F4
this is one for the books on how to
attack when your opponent is behind in
development as well as Hassan castle
with that king and the center and the
case striking at the right moment amen
is
yeah I don't know what to say this is
this is
not fun to watch Robert for MN
and I just have to applaud gukesh
because he went Rook B3 which seemed
like a pretty random move at the time
but it was for this purpose he saw the
future that he would have a blistering
attack and he brought that Rook that was
thing on B1 all the way up to G3 so so
much credit to go cash it is painful for
amino hanyan we feel for him but on the
other side of it is a superstar a
fantastic player I gotta stop saying I
need another synonym for good cash what
else can we call him at this point I've
complimented him that you go Bishop B it
rabbit Bishop be it Queen E7 is the only
move yeah what other name can you call
him a super duper Star Robin and that's
kind of just he's been playing look at
that Bishop A3 it's it's destruction
from both sides of the board from the
King side as well as the queen side and
I think that this could be the moment
that Eman decides to throw the towel in
this one you can't pick up the bishop on
E8 with the Queen the G7 Bishop is
hanging meanwhile white is ready to pick
up Black's material the Knight on B4
Falls
this Checkmate threat on G7 is too
overwhelming to deal with white is
winning back a piece that was sacrificed
and that means that you will have the
same attack without a material deficit
and that is a problem for black so
12 seconds on the clock Robert at this
point gokesh is just bullying this match
yes because he's that good he can do
what he wants uh when he is playing in
this style and black okay I mean trying
his best over here with those pawns but
now Bishop takes H6 is a threat you can
just take and play Bishop H6 if you want
that looks like it should be very good
good and strong and I think he's going
for it Bishop 86 there are ideas of
Queen G6 to follow and you could start
with Queen G6 now
Black's gotta go Rook it's seven
words sacrifice The Exchange over here
and just start pushing these Pawns
wow and let's not again never forget rub
it Black's got some pawns on the queen
side that can get a bit tricky for white
I I will not forget but look at White's
Pawn The Connect Four doesn't win you
this game this is chess and E6 yeah
comes to mind he takes a five apparently
was a huge blunder
what is there here E6 played I love it
Rook takes a five
grab it
oh my God Queenie it is fantastic will
cookies find it I think he will he's
a lot of things went here Queen F7 wins
on the spot you win more material Queen
E8 is Checkmate and that would be a
stunning finish he's got 50 seconds he's
looking at it Queenie it if you move the
king you lose the queen if you pick up
the queen you get checkmated Robert that
was a sweet tactic you spotted and I
just saw you guess he looked like he was
mean mugging over there he I think he
sees it and he's just uh he sees it
quadruple checking but Queen E8 is just
a I feel like I would resign the match
after that move Robin it's coming you
should be so proud of spotting this
queen E8 Rook G7 Rook F5 that's amazing
stuff and it's gonna happen
18 seconds it doesn't matter 17.
okay Robert he needs to make a move
yeah he is really getting low on time
here he needs to go
six five four three Robin what's going
on two
yeah he didn't find it and he said all
of his time isn't B1 equals Queen a
possibility here B1 equals Queen oh my
God
what is happening in this game
what happened there
I where did all of White's pieces whites
everything go
I and that's it gets checkmated
Robert that's it Eman wins the game
I'm in disability
what just happened I don't think either
player can believe it but you know
that's good for I mean he gets a win uh
there are some other positions that were
much cleaner than this but at this
moment here right after this capture on
E6 the Checkmate that we're mentioning
is Queenie a check you take Rook G7
check the King goes here Rook takes F5
you have no moves to your king so you
have to play Queen F7 and I don't know
they're probably like eight different
checkmates forcing sequences but I think
taking here and then just even Rook
takes B7 should probably be sufficient
but then maybe there's a better forcing
sequels but the queen sacrifice would
have let's Victory instead he lost the
game
wow a win for amino honey on from the
position that we had gokish dominating
missing that meeting idea that you just
spotted the tactic that would have been
game over just incredible stuff we saw
in this match but for Emin it means that
he can breathe a sigh of relief as he
comes back in this three plus one we've
got more action coming up first we're
gonna take a quick breather and then the
chest continues
[Music]
foreign
okay if I lose a game before I go to
sleep I have to play until I win and
once I win a game then I will play
another
why isn't my chess rating going up
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s we've ever seen in the junior speed
Chess Championship with that last win MN
does get the scoreboard going in the
three plus one section but still a far
away dream to make a comeback in the
match Robert
yeah he is still facing a huge deficit
against such a strong opponent in gukesh
12-3 is the score but at least I'm in
gotta win there and was a topsy-turvy
game but he should be feeling good about
the final result there could have been
five to zero in the three plus one and
we've still got 30 more minutes off the
three plus one segment and admin has to
try to narrow that margin even further
before he gets to the bullet where
in this format it could be his best
chance but gakesh is giving absolutely
no chances today he's a man on a mission
and he it is not mission impossible for
him he leads with a 12-3 he is the
number one seed in this year's Junior
speed chess championship for him of
course it is the prize money but more
than that it's about winning and booking
his spot in to the speed Chess
Championship the main speed Chess
Championship with the big boys playing
right now for Emin it's been a tough
ride so far all day and psychologically
Robert it's such a struggle to keep
going
it is but I think if either player is
particularly frustrated right now it not
might not be the the kid man I don't
know what to call them they're so young
uh the junior we see on the screen in
front of us because he just won with A5
as his first move did I mean ohanya that
was his first move it was tilt and
gukesh he lost the game to one A5 that
is something you don't think you'll say
yeah and look at that and then he looks
cheerful he knows he's the underdog in
the match you know he's playing against
a world top 15 player he's not playing
against somebody who is his age well
that's true but he's also playing
somebody who's one of the best players
in the world Emin is not taking the
pressure but he wants to make sure that
the man match can be as close as
possible and right now we are about to
lift off with a three plus one
Robert what are you expecting will the
score line get narrower
I don't think so just yet I think we'll
have to wait to the bullet before a
hunting can really strike gukesh has
been the better player today he is super
strong he's super informed he just is
coming off a successful Norway chess
event where he went toe-to-toe with all
the best players on the planet so for
good cash it just feels like he almost
can do no wrong
well so far he's been absolutely
excellent today in both time controls
eight to two in the five plus one and
then four to one in the three plus two
and we are waiting for the games to lift
off
ense amen with an uphill task right now
and we are Robert
I have the games begun
I'm not sure waiting for the action to
take part I think they will start very
soon so
uh yeah the games will be on their way
shortly
we are about to lift up really soon
right now for good cage this does look
like a blowout match that this has been
it's only the start and let's remind
everyone Robert that this is a single
elimination bracket you've got eight
players in the quarterfinals this is our
first match we have a second match
coming up as well right after this one
yeah we do and every single match in the
jscc features super strong talented
guess what Juniors it is the junior
speeches championship and it's
Christopher you taking on pranav so that
match will be very exciting that's the
four versus the five seed
wow and this is the action that's coming
up after dukesh versus m and Christopher
you from the United States and Prana
from India they will be battling it out
and again it's a single elimination it
is the end of the road if you're knocked
out you're knocked out of the event and
it's fifty thousand dollars on the line
and the big ticket to the speed Chess
Championship but right now it is all
about can Emin try to make a comeback in
this match can he at least narrow down
the score enough to have a chance to
have a shot in the bullet segment we
know that we're all waiting for the
bullet anything can happen there right
now we're waiting for the games to kick
off and again Chad we're just having
some tactical difficulties they will be
resolved soon and we'll have the action
going
yes indeed and for amino well he just
wants to get to the bullet of this stage
he's already tilted he played A5 on his
first move he just wants to play some
games with a super Grand Master not a
bad way to spend your Tuesday and
speaking of super Grand Masters on
Tuesday title Tuesday happens twice on
each Tuesday and it just started nine
minutes ago and I I got word Tanya that
there were 20 players rated over 3 000
in Blitz in title Tuesday
that's insane title Tuesday is perhaps
the strongest chest ornament that
happens it happens weekly it happens
twice on Tuesday it's time travel
Tuesday all along we're seeing that in
the jscc and today's style Tuesday as
you're mentioning 20 players over 3 000
rating on chesscom just insane stuff and
I think the list of grand monsters just
goes on and on and on and I'm just
wondering in the title Tuesday Robert
today do we have Magnus and Hikaru
fighting it out while we wait for the
action here to start
I believe that Magnus is playing I
didn't get the specifics I just saw the
number so uh you know that's bad
management by me I should have really
been looking at the specifics uh but I
use the break to stretch my legs what do
you think the players do on their break
right kukesh is leading and Ohanian just
wants to score some points if we're
being realistic the match is quite out
of hand uh so what do you think they
were getting up to did they prepping at
all
I think MN just wants this day to be
over Robert it's been a tough fight for
him and with the score margin that we're
seeing right now he wants this nightmare
to end as soon as possible but of course
the players have to fight at that and
they have to do the best that they can
it's not a good place for MN meanwhile
gakesh he could just be enjoying his
lead he knows it's almost unsurmountable
for all practical purpose he's already
pretty much won the match for Emin the
nightmare continues
yeah although there is prize money
attached to each and every game that's
part of the speed chess championship
format where the winner gets half of the
allotted prize fund plus the percentage
of games that they win so if uh the
price one for this particular match is 3
500 that's a lot of money so the winner
gets 17.50 1 750 plus the percentage
that they score so that's a lot at stake
in each and every game
yeah you've got to play for the dollars
as uh Magnus said you've got to earn
your dollars and speaking of Magnus chat
is informing us and updating us that in
fact entitled Tuesday some of the
players were above 3 000 there's a
certain Magnus playing Hikaru is playing
nehals playing fabies playing do-bomb
and drykin the list goes on and on the
chest doesn't stop on chesscom wait can
can the list keep going I'm actually
curious who else is in the field because
if that's not a Powerhouse field I don't
know what is so keep listening those
names because that is ridiculous
chat Keep It Coming keep us updated with
that action while we wait for the games
to kick off here for the players there's
a lot to fight for in the junior speed
Chess Championship so gokish it is about
making it to the speeches Championship
where he will be playing against the
likes of Magnus and Hikaru and Fabiano
and Robert I believe we do have liftoff
we do indeed and gukesh has the white
pieces in uh this game from what I'm
seeing here and he has this variation
that we see on the board black has these
pawns that are doubled and isolated but
what you also have is great control over
the D5 Square Bishop that's just gone to
B7 so Tanya in your experience you know
commentating or playing which side do
you prefer because I have really mixed
feelings about this opening
is about playing gokish I would prefer
no
I'm not dating on any of his games but
given the position I do like White's
chances here it just feels especially in
these bullet and Blitz formats Robert
when you're on the defense and when your
king is feeling unsafe it's just such an
unpleasant feeling and we see this nice
Rook lift by gokish getting it into the
attack Rook H3 Rook G3 black skin has to
play the defense and the problem with
that is that the Rook on h8 is out of
the game for a very long time and very
often in these kind of positions black
just ends up playing without a rope
meanwhile White's Rook is already
joining the party in the center you can
sidestep with the queen to G4
threatening a basic but a big threat
with Queen G7
and how do you stop it Rook G8 is the
usual way that may walk in the bishop
takes H6 because there'll be a pin on
the G file Rook H7
still walks into Bishop takes H6 Bishop
H6 that's the move
that's the move and that could be the
game Robin as you're pointing out he
first hits the queen wherever the queen
moves Bishop 86 is still in the air it's
happened and this might just be game
over for Emin you've got the brilliant C
Mark there black can't pick up the
bishop with the pawn there's a mate on
G8 you pick up the bishop with the Rook
the queen steps into G7 gives a check
wins The Rook on it six and I have and
I'm afraid Robert this is already over
yeah and look at that double exclamation
point I'm with it that is sick down the
G file you told me not to forget about
the G file I don't think Gucci forgot
either Tanya he's using the G file it's
open he has a queen and a rook on it
barreling down so Bishop takes H6 if you
take with a pawn queen Jade is made take
with the Rook Queen takes G7 hits the
king hits The Rook you're winning
material so this is a knockout blow
this is amazing and
we're seeing moves being blitzed out but
it really doesn't matter
what picks up the other Pawn on G7
Black's King stuck in the center you
could go Bishop F6 Queen G8 is a massive
threat on the board winning that Rook
you could also simply pick up the bishop
on F6 just keep all the threats alive
another problem of Plenty here really
good ways to win you can't go King E7
because white would have picked up the
bishop with a check one massive material
amen just resigns doesn't want any more
of the torture
no he does not and it's another victory
for good cash and we should note that
while we experience slight technical
difficulties go cash had scored a
victory in that time so the score right
now is just overwhelming gukesh game
after game is performing uh at his best
and by the way this position I know I
just asked you about an opening this
line I've always found it to be shaky
because uh Black's Pawn structure on the
queen side is compromised white storms
forward on the king side so I think
Ohana has the style of game that he
wants right now
I don't know what Ohanian wants anymore
Robert it's really difficult to say
because he's not only fighting kakesh
he's not only fighting the position he's
fighting his own mind right now given
the score line it's the point where you
start giving up any hopes of making an
actual comeback in the match and I think
he's already crossed that about a
hundred games ago for honey and this is
just about trying to keep at least
trying to keep the game going maybe
picking up a win or two he knows that
this is much over he wants to try to
finish on a high note but right now he's
fighting too many battles including his
own mind
yeah I mean fighting your mind when
you're struggling is not a fun process
but for Ohanian he goes Bishop D6 he
cuts off that Rook from the White Queen
on D2 and if you can swing this queen on
over to the king side
we could see a checkmating attack that
black king is in a lot of trouble right
now
you really want to line up the rook and
the Queen on the king side the bishop on
D6 plays a really important role and
look at the way amen does it we've been
saying that it's a tough battle but he
is fighting he's fighting for those
points G3 it does not only attack the
Knight on F4 but clears the route for
the queen to go to H2 start hitting that
pawn on 8-7 yes black can plant a knight
on H5 but it's not a stable Knight white
just moves with the pawn to G4
and that night can't stay there for too
long
so Bishop C4 look at how quickly I mean
play that why
I mean I was surprised by that move and
I didn't think he had to do it so fast
there was definitely an attack Brewing
on the H file
yeah and it gets across and the eval bar
shoots right down Queen H2 looked like
such an attractive
normal standard move to play in this
position but Bishop C4 and I'm wanting
to know Robert what's the drawback of
this move he goes back with the bishop
to F7 and white can still go Queen H2
Knight G5 in the air Queen H2 in the air
just always be careful about that Bishop
on D6 you've got to time the moves
correctly I would play Queen H2
in this position and I'm in there with a
smile
I wonder what he's looking at because uh
that a moment ago seemed like black had
an opportunity I wonder what it was
maybe we can quickly try to analyze to
see what was available there I'm gonna
just cheat I'm gonna be honest I'm gonna
use the okay
Rook D6 Knight D6 Queen C5 this Knight
is under attack and if the Knight moves
the bishop is lost and if Bishop takes
D5 you take back with the pawn and the
Knight is in trouble in enemy territory
so that feels like a very easy thing to
miss in a super difficult thing to find
so I don't blame either player for
overlooking that instead we see the
bishop come back to C5 the queen goes
back to C7 and now it is uh a huge
Advantage for ohanyon and I'm trying to
figure out where the Checkmate comes
from definitely on the H7 Square
it's seven square but also I really like
the option of jumping in with the Knight
to G5 I hit the H7 with the Knight as
well as the bishop on F7 Queen H2 Knight
G5 2 attractive options for white the
only thing not attractive is once again
the clock management he needs to he
needs to make a choice he needs to do it
now
Okay so uh 58 seconds and counting down
whoa
Rook H7
yeah he's just gonna go over to the H
file and there's no H5 push so he
eliminated the one piece the smallest
piece the least valuable piece on the
board that could have stopped the
checkmating attack
okay this is incredible stuff and I
think it's really important Robert that
you don't start with Queen H2 because
that allows Bishop 86 and the black king
to run to G7 so after King takes eight
seven you have to start with Knight to
G5 check Force the king back and then
get the queen to the H5 and notice how
that Bishop on C5 is a power piece
blocking Black's King into the Kill Zone
No f8 Square
this is game over for gkesh so Emin he
took his time but he found the killer
blow this time yeah and that's maybe why
he was looking at the cameras like does
this work do I have this and yeah he
found it what a shot and he's a tactical
player I mean he enjoys these types of
positions so you know out of the opening
I was saying that it looked like a good
opportunity for him and he finds Rook
taxation that is one of the moves of the
match
agree completely agree he thought okay
this works as well this is beautiful you
go Queen H2 Queen at seven Knight G5 was
the other way to do it he finds this one
97 trying to stay alive but Robert
there's got to be a killer blow here
Queen at seven King f8 you can maybe
just
um Queen S7 was and inaccuracy it wasn't
that
oh my gosh
and now it's Eva and I are both trying
to figure out
that
oh my God
will show us I I think I see something
I'm gonna very quickly pull up an
analysis board for us because Knight F6
check you can't take because if you take
Queen H7 King here queen of seven is
mate that doesn't work but if you after
Knight F6 you play King of f8 there's
Queen h8 check does this work because
you can't block I take it your knight is
pinned after King G7 Rook H7 check Kink
takes Rook F7 check King here Bishop E3
check King H5 Rook H7 is made that is
six stuff
that would have been fire on board
Robert you're on fire today what is this
insane line you can't blame the players
for not finding it but what an
incredible mating sequence that was
sacrificing a piece sacrificing the
queen let's get up to date with the live
board and this is where we are after
everything that happened this dust
settles down and gokish is winning and
now he's not this is what happens in in
Blitz chest you just start scrambling
trying to find moves a queen C3
apparently not the best but looks like a
pretty good move just trying to solidify
your King's defense and white has a
knight and three pawns for a rook
what Black's got to do is already start
lining up you can't go G4 because then
Black Goes Rook G4 and uses the pin
along the f file so you've got to use
the Knight to defend that G3 pawn and
look at that he goes Rook G4 anyway
that's a beautiful move you can pick up
the pawn on F3 and I think this is just
a balanced position
Troy is the most likely result but the
players are playing on seconds yeah so
because the time I don't think it draws
that likely somebody is going to make a
mistake and I wouldn't be surprised if
it's black 94 to D6 watch out for night
Forks everywhere
Knight's a super tricky piece and we see
Rooks are being offered to trade
White Spot structures super intact on
the queen side even if the Rooks were
off the board they should still end in a
draw but it's all about the time right
now because 17 seconds on the clock
I'm in under five seconds
I think that Emma's trying to win this
game I do think 93 there it is Knight C3
on the board
and dukesh just missed it look at that
shake of his head but he's still got
enough to hold it's two versus three on
the same side but Emma's gonna try to
pull this one out of the bag
yeah he's gonna try to slowly just make
some moves maybe a C3 of B4 uh but he
should not be winning this game in fact
the black king is in the perfect
position
and we see the player shuffling around
Emin right now not sure of what's the
plan to try and improve he eventually
makes a pawn move you've got to try to
watch down that board B4 comes in after
the trade he wants to put the Rook on C3
get the king up the board and at nine
seconds for the case to decide what he
wants to do with the pawn he refuses the
trade
this is getting tricky to defend
yeah I mean he's going back and forth a
bit and he had to stop B5 that's why he
took on B4 and now the pawns are split
so that could be bad news for white
because harder to push a pass Pawn you
want to pawn with it but on the other
hand maybe you can throw in an A5 or a
C5 the right moment if Black's not
looking out for it
right moment because
at least put the Rook on the fifth rank
a5c5 is hard to achieve and at the
moment I say that he walks into it but
now he can stop just giving checks and
then eventually putting pressure on the
C Pawn
um wow
be a bit careful Robert why it's allowed
to check on eight seven things could get
out of hand yeah the good news is for
good cash this Rook on B1 is on the B
file rather is perfectly placed and the
white king can't cross the line the
white king would love to get the B6 but
that's not gonna happen
and if you go A5 black and gold Rook B5
and start picking up the pawns and he
does exactly that
I think there's no way to improve this
position that's it oh it gives him
that's clever he wants King B6
and you give a check on A6 and you get
the position the defensive position that
you want another clever move Rook 87.
I think that oh honey I'm doing this
perfectly considering it's a uh scramble
here he's just trying to win this Pawn
on his own terms and he wants a rook D6
he's making things a little bit tricky
super tricky the moment he picks up that
pawn he needs to make sure that black
doesn't have a check and that's it oh
it's winning
because he didn't have to check on the
sixth rank this is amazingly played by
Emin
yes no really tricky stuff and he wins
the game he was gonna rookie two check
he's gonna build the bridge with the
past pawn and he gets that win that was
an earned victory
super good stuff and both players
they're smiling gukesh knows as well he
got tricked there but very convincing
they played there by Eminem reacting
celebrating a bit he's had two
back-to-back wins and that's something
to celebrate about
yeah you know I have to be happy for him
because he struggled throughout the
match and even gukesh who's crushing him
in the match is also probably a bit
happy for him because you know he knows
how strong oh hanyan is when he's
playing his best chess it's a much more
combative match than we've seen thus far
but credit to gukesh because when he's
playing his best chess and this was even
the slightest bit off he is going to
dominate matches like this That's How
Strong he is as you said he's not just
this a kid who's happy to be in the
tournament he wants to win the whole
thing and then he wants to play in the
speed Chess Championship and then he
wants to start beating some of the top
players in the world there he played
Magnus Carlson in the 2022 speed Chess
Championship and he lost and it was a
one-sided match in the final score but
he took seven games off of Magnus and he
made Magnus sweat at various moments so
you have to love what uh gukesh does on
the chessboard he's such a strong player
but Ohanian he's making this more of a
match more competitive in each and every
game
definitely the last two games definitely
a drop of sweat there on gakesh and we
saw the feature chat about from Krishna
I think it was that Rook Bond endings
are a pain Gigi that was big Gigi for
emmanuhanian as he avoided any philadel
defenses of the sixth rank making it
tricky in a drawn end game using the
clock keeping the game alive not walking
into a technical theoretical draw some
great gameplay practical play there by
Emin in that last game but what is this
wild position that we have in this one
Robert H file is open again this was
disastrous in the last one there's a big
threat on the board threatening a mate
with sacrificing on G6 you probably have
to step up with the King to G7 not only
defending the G6 Pawn but also hitting
that Rook on 86. oh the rook's not
really under attack because if you could
make two moves and take there's Knight
takes F7 and after King G7 there may be
Knight E6 check look at that right
there's Rook takes G6 first but 96 ideas
the point is that this king is getting
mated so we've seen a lot of mating Nets
So It's Tricky territory here for Ohan
Young
King G7 just walks into 96 and that's a
great tactical trick once again
someone's been doing their puzzle Rush
Robert you've been on fire with the
tactics today loving it but if you don't
have King G7 Rook G6 is a massive threat
how are you fighting it and I see that
emin's also struggling to find a way
he's down to almost a minute on the
clock
I think my process of elimination with
Rook takes G6 being a winning threat
maybe bishop f8 I'm not saying with the
most confidence because this Rook HH
check ideas but he walked right into
this 96 idea
and he starts with Rook 36 the same idea
as you mentioned but he switches up the
move order and I think I meant might
have which is very well missed that
because we see him shaking his head
there and once again out of the opening
dukesh is winning but we've seen massive
turnarounds so I'm not gonna call this
over just yet
wait he goes Rook takes D2 uh he won he
won he was hoping for some tricky fork
or something but there were the Knight
was pinned so it wouldn't have worked
out regardless so he smiled at the end
he was kind of like all right that
wasn't my game
no I wasn't and it was clear from the
start as gokish managed to build a big
attack in that Queen's Gambit Decline
and finished it with a knockout blow on
the G6 Square we've got another Sicilian
Cecil for the kill FICA his opening
strategy has been on point so far in
this match he's played many different
openings he played like a modern at some
point he's just been mixing and matching
and I think in even hippo type of
variation so I think in these matches in
this format he's willing to take more
risks because time Patrol it's a quicker
pace so what's going on in this game it
looks like white has given up the bishop
pair but has also secure this E4 Square
for the Bishops or the knights whatever
you want to put there you can
and this potentially could be the final
game in the three minute with a one
second increment segment we see just
four and a half about four and a half
minutes left so not those many games in
the three minute Blitz section after
which we will have the bullet and look
at that score line eight to two and five
plus one seven to two in three plus one
Robert a blowout of a match
and for Emin it's been a tough day in
the office
it certainly has been but he's fighting
and when we get to Bullet I think he
will score some victories he'll earn
some additional cash in terms of the
prize fund so I I just want to say that
I think if I were playing this match and
it you know would be one side in
gukesh's favor I'd be dejected I'd
probably just throw in the towel maybe
even resign the match as soon as I could
but I like that he is still fighting
each and every game because he wants to
score wins and it's a great opportunity
to play against a top level player
yeah these kids are Fighters they do not
give up and Robert it's so easy to do
that for Emin it's such a big
opportunity to be able to play in the
junior speed Chess Championship the
seedings did not work in his favor that
he has to play gokish in the first round
the top seed he knows he's a heavy heavy
Underdog every game is a learning
experience
and this game might reward him if black
is not careful that's why Lucas is
pausing right now it's a critical moment
of this game if you make some kind of
aimless move like Queen to C7 Queen B3
is going to hurt your king is in the
line of fire your Bishop will be
directly under attack so Queen F6 is
played to keep in touch in contact with
this bishop on B2 and 94 white is much
better here
uh this is looking very tricky the
threats combining the Knight The Rook
and the Queen the idea of Queen B3 the
loose pieces that black has with the
bishop on B2 it can get very dangerous
really quickly Queen B3 I think black
will be forced to step away with the
King Emin doesn't hurry he gets greedy
with the pawn
Rookery seven Queen B3 I'm loving both
these options right now
this black king is definitely uh in
trouble right now Rook D7 also frees the
D5 Square for a check against this King
so if you saw me playing Queen B3 I
might just play Queen to D5 and I love
this position for amino hunting and he's
out playing gookesh in this game
and that's really something to take
solace in and drop it again wrong
direction you can't get greedy right now
you have to go for more than just a pawn
Rook D7 Queen B3 ideas the one thing
that white needs to watch out for is
back rank weaknesses but we see gokish
returning the favor not easy to see why
Bishop d154 was an inaccuracy and oh
honey it just goes on with the pawn hunt
yeah one thing that all you need to be
careful about is his King on H1 Rook
takes F4 ideas are in the air because
his background Checkmate but Rook takes
F4 there might be Rook B8 check so black
king will be black black mate check back
rink Checkmate first so it's a back rank
Checkmate threat indeed and queen D7
that looks pretty powerful but maybe
there's no there's not Quinn H4 because
The Bishop's hanging
I love Queen D7 it's on the board and
this might just be game over for good
cage I don't see a way how you're
defending you might have to go back
Queen G7 but a queen trade means all
those extra pawns you can even decide
not to trade Queens I don't see another
option except Queen G7 here
so you can trade Queens if you want if
uh you just want to liquidate and say
I'm gonna try to win the end game a
white is up three Pawns
three I didn't even count until this
moment so I would be tempted to trade
but I also feel like white probably has
better I mean queen D5 back queen of six
would be force and then maybe H3 just
makes space for your king uh this should
be an opportunity for oh honey on the
strike
and with this being the last game of the
three-minute segment it would be great
for him to be able to strike in this one
get a bit of that confidence before
moving on to the bullet and of course as
the clock runs low the time format gets
lower you have to rely more on your
intuition and to be able to do that
confidence is key he keeps the Queens on
the board Robert I was critical about
his decision of going Pawn hunting I'm
gonna eat my words and say that that's
really paying off right now and we see
the three extra pawns it's really a big
asset in White's position
three extra pawns is quite a number and
H3 was played he made space for his King
created Luft so the king can slap to H2
there are no problems in the back rank
anymore at least not for the time being
and queen D7 that Queen can always go
back there if you need the A6 Knight is
hanging but Queen takes D4 check would
be a big problem for black so Bishop E5
what a concept nice
yeah it's a really cool concept and it's
not winning for white but the thing is
this really creates a bit of a mess in
the position it forces MN to pause and
think and that's exactly what gakesh is
hoping for he's playing on the clock
right now using the pin along the f file
using the fact that the Knight on A6 was
hanging finally the queen is free rook
H3 is in the air white still cannot pick
up that Bishop on E5 The Rook from f8
will pick up that Rook on F1 and I think
Rook H3 is a legit threat because you
trade it
you give up The Rook a check on G3 when
the queen falls back there's a check on
D4 with the bishop so a lot of Big Ideas
in the position
anybody's King G1 now Rook Hitcher is
met by Queen takes E5 check first and
then Black's King is being hunted first
so uh that was a Miss apparently not the
best move but I think it's a good move
considering the time on the clock
and I can't believe that white black has
got time to pick up the F4 Pawn because
white just simply you know what there's
no check on the back rank actually I was
gonna say give a check on the backtrack
but it doesn't exist because the queen
defends D.A and we're seeing another
time around oh no Queen takes a four
that's made on H2 checkmate
so he gives up the queen and he is just
losing the game because he's gonna be
down to Queen for rook and he just
laughs but that is a left so you don't
cry
that is painful it was a great game by
Eminem he kept things under control and
he knows he was the one in driver's seat
he was so close to taking that point
this is a disappointing disappointing
end to that one and a disappointing end
for Emin in the three-minute segment
Robert kokesh takes the last game
he has played an excellent match has
gukesh he is winning this by uh such a
huge margin but we're about to get into
the bullet so you know Anya knows he
cannot win this match that is
mathematically impossible but if you
have a lot of fun in the process playing
some bullet against the Super Jam
uh he's gonna have a lot of fun playing
bullet
try not to think about the score and
drop it for us one plus one a bullet it
means super entertainment chat you don't
want to miss that it's the most fun part
and it is coming up really soon after
this shot break we'll be right back
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kit is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
thank you
is I was here I was I was lost oh okay
well hey
let's go oh no I think you should have
just done that sure I got 14. we beat it
let's go no 15 unreal no first try eight
in a row nine in a row baby let's go
let's go let's go
I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool
come at chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
[Music]
foreign
thank you
30 minutes of bullet action that's gonna
be Adrenaline Rush Happening Here Robert
this has been just an absolutely beastly
performance by gokish he's running away
with this one for Emin I think the next
30 minutes into the bullet is about
having fun forgetting the score line
just trying to have as much fun as he
can with the bullet
yes hard to forget about the match
that's been taking place but now he
knows the match is over he's going to
lose but he can earn some more money he
can play bullet against the top player
that is fun and that's things that most
players do in their free time anyway
yeah it's uh chat it means a lot of fun
for us super entertaining stuff well
kukesh has been a favorite from the
start on paper he is of course got a
higher rating he's a grand master Robert
and we see some stats there and you're
one who disagrees with smarter chess
predictions you're a rebel out there but
this one Robert I think smarter chess
got it right well I think he undersold
good Cash's chances and his scores
because cash has won eight to two in
both the five minute plus one second
increment time control and the three
plus one but we're getting into the one
plus one that's when there's just
craziness chaos one plus one usually
equals two but in bullet chest it equals
stress and blunders and well a lot of
fun for spectators
what blunders this guy in front of us
has barely made any blunders today he's
got a phenomenal score in both the five
plus one and the three plus one but we
know that bullet is a different animal
it's a different Beast altogether and
for Evan it's an opportunity to end on a
high to have some fun Chad get ready to
get entertained we've got a liftoff and
it starts with an opening that we've
seen plenty of times in this match once
again a Carlsbad structure coming up and
we might be seeing opposite side
castling yeah we started a Queen's
Gambit declined the bishop slides in E5
we have seen a knight replace that
bishop and then gookest goes for the
attack so I wonder if Ohanian looked at
this during the break if you prepared a
little bit but instead we're seeing both
players cast on the king side so it's a
quieter affair
a quieter fair and very often the plan
on this side of the board will be that
you try the minority attack and that's
definitely on vocation's agenda the
other plan on his agenda is on his mind
is to advance with the F Pawn F4 F5 and
it's on the board it's coming
yeah F5 does allow this Knight to go
into G5 so you have to time it well but
it takes on C5 instead and that leaves
his weakness behind on E3 so Bishop
takes E5 looks very promising Rook to E1
maybe there's a D4 move now or in the
near future
things are getting tricky D4 I love it
you hit the Knight you hit the pawn on
E3 but I think the point is that white
can simply recapture and sidestep with
the King and all of White's pieces are
ideally placed for the center opening up
a lot of pressure on black right now
Ohanian continues to develop lining up
with the Queen the queen side steps the
bar drops although I have to say that
that was a very natural looking move by
gokish
all the moves played thus far have
looked very reasonable to me I'm
wondering at some point Bishop takes E3
as possible Rook E3 D4 not So Much
Anymore now the bishop went to F5 but
I'm looking for ideas like that kind of
to simplify because I see way too many
white pieces in Black's camp
and I see way too much of a deficit on
the clock as well once again for Eminem
he's down to about 20 seconds and that's
a 15 a 19 second Advantage for gokish
right now in bullet you have to play the
clock as much as the position he needs
to start moving fast Robert or this
segment will also end in heartbreak for
The Armenian youngster well 94 was a
good move watch out for Knight G3 check
that's why I brought the Knight up here
and apparently Rook takes E7 was a
mistake probably Queen takes E7 was
better to avoid the queen trade and we
see this position and I love it for
white this bishop we usually like
Bishops overnight but Tanya the bishop
stares into its own Pawn
yeah all they want to do is get rid of
that E4 Pawn but that pawn is there for
life even if white can grab it for free
dukesh will not do it opening up that
Bishop on C6 he's eyeing that Bishop on
C6 also a doubling up on the d-line is
on the cards and always the F Pawn
marching down the board is a threat you
cannot ignore have to have it in your
mind compare all the pieces white pieces
so much more active than blacks 995 is
such a strong piece and F6 kicks that
Knight out of there the Knight can go
forward to G6 that looks dangerous but
back to C4 maybe even more so because
the pawn on B6 is loose
Bond structure absolutely horrible for
black he loses one of the pawns B2 is
hanging gokish defends it with the move
B3 he's just up an extra healthy Pawn
can start targeting the E4 Pawn now oh
and forking the Rooks Knights are so
strong in bullet chess this game isn't
completely over there's still some
chances for black because it is bullet
but I wouldn't be surprised I was going
to say if Google decides to liquidate he
is now up two Pawns in a rook end game
a really nice practical decision there
you just straight out the pieces so
there are no tricks and now he's gonna
win up win the other Pawn or force or
King Pawn ending and that is it Emin
resigns starts the next one and we've
got liftoff
this time with the black pieces
yeah we're getting this line again sharp
variations but wait you saying with the
black people guess white in that other
game in this exact line
yeah
I think both players have played this
line with the white pieces and the black
pieces but this time it's kokesh playing
that kind it's getting very tricky
already Robert once again we see the
Knight is on D5 Bishop C4 and this time
it's gokish going into a bit of a thing
which is good news for admin Emin
playing fast
I've been playing fast playing well and
if we do a quick material count black is
actually down upon that double Pawn C4
is gone because wipe at A4 A5 to kick
the Knight out from its perch on B6 so I
like this position for white I think
it's excellent chances and black doesn't
have an idea Black's a bit cramped and
white simply developing protecting the
pawn of B2 that frees up this bishop to
develop I really like how White's
playing this game
where
is nowhere
right and it also it all down dude
are we objectively white doing really
well Queenie for the first inaccuracy by
Emin Bishop 86 is always in the air the
Knight jumpsuit before what black wants
is to try and get C5 in you want to
break the center try and create some
targets for your pieces
it's not going to be easy meanwhile MN
targeting Black's King H4 H5 in the air
h4h5 looks very good in standard you can
take on C5 play 90 E4 oh my goodness
this Knight is about to sink its teeth
into score like D6 that looks like a
problem for black
oh nice find
wow and that's not just win the Beast
yet yeah reacting knows that he missed
it out and uh that's it MN takes the
point he reacted and he resigned he's
like I can't look at this position
anymore that was a nice game from Ohio
it's what we said from the beginning if
this match were within three points I
really did believe that Ohio would have
chances he would still be the underdog
because of that one second increment but
he's a super talented bullet player is
Amin ohanyan and we just saw that on
full display that was an excellent game
from him
yeah and then when it comes to Bullet
robot you can take the ratings the
predictions and throw them out of the
window you can burn them it doesn't
matter it's bullet anything can happen
but there is a big Point deficit because
of the five plus one and the three plus
one and we see fire on the board already
again a line that we've seen the two of
them employ in this match gokish has
been loving Harry the H Pawn it's been
marching down the board in several of
the games and now with that last move
Emin he eyes that E5 Pawn because of the
H4 H5 Advance kakesh losing a lot of
time to finish development he sacrifices
the E5 Bond
yeah taking that pawn and trying to play
G3 and F4 and going for an attack but it
doesn't feel sufficient I think oh look
at that move stopping any F4 ideas and
trying to get to this lonely H5 Pawn so
Tanya I haven't forgotten about it you
told me several games ago the G file
Rook G8 I'm still looking at it and that
was a good move defending the pawn G4
never forget Robert and and not only
does it depend upon on G4 there are
ideas of Rook G5 and picking up the H5
Pawn at some point as well the only
problem for Emin right now is that his
King is in the center and that could
always give play the C5 Pawn is a bit
loose you gotta make some decisions and
precise moves here he falls back with
the queen and immediately the bar shoots
up that just shows how difficult the
position is yeah but up and down it goes
Rook takes D4 was the move because that
Queen was loose on C7 casting queenside
defends the king from the center but
also defends the queen so Rook 64 is no
longer an option and black is better
here I think that amazing playing great
in both mistakes are going to happen
everybody the bar will go up and down
it's like a seesaw roller coaster
whatever is your fancy there but Rook to
C1 apparently mistake is that d-pawn
just going to roll down the board
Black's got two extra pawns and no clear
weaknesses here white is just waiting
for the clock to go even lower and
potentially a blunder you said the
d-pawn's marching down the boat yes it
started I don't care whether the eval
bar creeps up or not Robert D3 it does
look close to winning the queen is
attacked right now but you could go D2
take it take it take the rook and then
play D2
oh
yeah that looks like game over actually
but then maybe that's Rook D6 in that
position and it kind of still goes on
yeah the game does go on there that's a
good point so maybe I'll just Queen D7
and it's still better for black maybe
not the best move but still a good
enough this Pawn's going to D2 whether
you like it or not
yeah it's just a check D2 now Robert
your idea does does it work well he
finds the right move admin with Queen A4
D2 always in the air he controls the D1
square and now there's no stopping it
black White's King will end up getting
checkmated
yeah look at this it's a scramble over
here where both sides oh Queen B4 check
was a mistake somehow there must be an
attack against the black king
who cares it's two seconds but I'm in
four seconds we can't expect a lot of
shuffling around of the bar g387 blade
and now white is completely winning yeah
but how can you go to B7 Rook B7
oh I think that is Rook B7 there Robert
it's made what just happened that was
wild
ah this is wild this is bullet chess
it's bound to happen checkmates misses
hits and misses blunders and brilliances
we're seeing all of that being played at
and with that third game kakesh with a
2-1
lead in the bullet and bullet chest is
never smooth but this is the type of
dynamic that I thought Amino honey would
want from the beginning where yes he
would make mistakes but he would drag
gukesh into positions where mistakes are
more likely to happen just really feisty
positions with chances for both sides
but the control that that's the word you
use and it's a great one to describe how
googkesh is played very controlled very
measured throughout this entire match it
always felt like he had a handle on the
positions until we get to Bullet when
nobody has a handle in any position
and we've always said that is the best
strategy for
Underdog in this match format try to
narrow down the margin with the longer
time controls and then take it to Bullet
it is that deep dark Forest on Mikhail
tal which is just wide enough for one of
the players to come out a forest of
complications and that's exactly what
you want when you take want to take down
a higher rated opponent and we see this
position
I like black hair Robert simply
comparing the pawn structures it feels
like gkesh is out of the opening without
too much trouble that Bishop on G3 kind
of hitting against a brick wall which is
his own pawns no problem for black and
on the clock as well up now the one
thing that I would say black needs to be
careful about is this D file and the the
King on G8 H5 saying I'm Not Afraid
about my own King uh but I am a little
bit concerned about this King if this
queen can line up in the D file and go
into the position so he goes Knight f8
Knight G6 okay no longer am I worried
about the black king
yeah because now you're worried about
the H football and the E5 Pawn which
both come in the which both come
undefiled once the Knight arrives on G6
but that would allow Queen d8 to trade
and activity of the Rook The Rook could
also start threatening the pawns on the
Queen's side he starts with the King
moves gokish wants to keep the Queens on
the board making it even trickier watch
out for the Rook coming to d8 knight
from G6 will got the h8 square so it's
not checkmate
wow what is happening here White's going
after pawns on the queen side Knight
takes E5
you have to take that thing I don't
think you want to allow Knight G4
I think you've got to take that Knight
on E5 Knight G4 with all the ideas on
the back rank looks really scary but
giving up that dark Square Bishop it
means a lot of weaknesses around the
king and he does allow the Knight to
jump into G4
I think
yeah you could just go Rook F1 Rook F1
trying to get the queen over to H1 that
looks good enough but the evapor is
going back
you're such a natural move and once
again Dave albar says what are you
talking about but it's the move that
everyone wants to make and it forces
Evan into a think tank down to five
seconds four seconds
and Bishop
Queen H20 misses it
ladies and gentlemen this is bullet for
you
it really is and that was a scramble and
he was putting up good defense in fact
the eval bar was suggesting that he was
right back in the game but then you
blunder checkmated one and the game is
over so we see look at this line in the
slav pieces are being captured what's
the material count black is up a pawn
and I think that this is a fun variation
this is bullet chest as you said
every game has been a fun variation with
these two the openings have often ended
up in a fiery middle game and it's been
super entertaining to watch
unfortunately for MN it's been going in
gkesh's way from the start and now again
is taking the lead in the bullet as well
I do like White's position that Apon
marching down the board the Double C
pawns the C4 Pawn can be picked up at
any moment he decides now is the right
time the F pawns doubled up as well
Robert de valver says it's fine for
black but I wouldn't be pleased if I was
Emin right now yeah Pawn structure
problems although the good news for uh
black is you're putting pressure in the
center and on the queen side so I do
think that there are some chances for
black this Knight and F6 can hop up to
E4 there will be a lot of activity and
by the way Ohio is up on time for like
the first time today
quite a bit this is
and good
good can mock Bishop C5 a queen trade on
the offer the Knight jumps in there are
always threats of a fork watch out for
Knight E7 the bishop and C5 for now Gods
it white can play Rook to D1 getting
that Center file but first he goes
Bishop E3 do not pick up that Bishop 97
was a trap yeah so we went Rook E8 just
covering the square and I like the way
that both players are here obituary six
check
he has to go back to G8 where is the
Naga Knight B4 comes to mind but I don't
think that's sufficient there is an idea
here he plays Rook B1 how could you
blame for getting the Rook to B7
I love it Rook B7 and if you've got Rook
D6 here you might have to play Rook D6
but then you go Rook D7 anyway with
Knight F6 to follow so this Knight needs
to move but where two Knight of Fate
very passive
uh
night night
six Rook F6 and you get the other Rook
to D7 Robert that's an idea instead he
plays Bishop G5 also really strong you
can't move the Rope the night falls and
F6 runs into Knight F6 and this is game
over
sometimes it's hacking a rook with your
Bishop is just the best way to go and it
wins the game for gukesh he's looking
powerful in the bullet as well I I think
this is a good sign for him in the
overall jscc because his next opponent
uh next point will be the winner of the
later match between pranav and
Christopher you both of those players
are fantastic in Blitz and really really
sharp in bullet so the fact that gookash
is you know hanging in there and playing
excellent bullet chess is a big deal by
the way this line is when I played as a
child if Castle's King side F5 this gets
very dangerous for black
doesn't know how to handle it or hasn't
really revised the theory recently it's
so easy to get into trouble really
quickly he plays the move eight six NBC
he's burnt the clock quite a bit he's
not super familiar with it or at least
he's trying to remember the theory
Robert the good news is he's not going
to get checkmated anytime soon but he's
given a big Edge to White look at that
the pawn going down to H4 you can't pick
it up the G7 Pawn will fall King D1
defending Knight C2 but that felt
strange yeah candy one was I guess maybe
a move slow but now he's stealing the G5
Pawn but look at that black was able to
Castle so King D1 I think you were
supposed to give up material we usually
have time to analyze in bullet but I'm
gonna do it I'm sorry everybody let's
look at that variation because I'm
pretty sure uh if my memory serves me
correctly from my childhood that a movie
like Rook H3 and then you give up this
rook in the corner and just go after the
black king because after Rook takes H3
Queen takes H3 this queen is getting in
here and the king is being hunted so you
give up a rook because black hasn't
developed it's a a very very nasty
variation that's hard to meet especially
with no time of the clock
but it's still super nasty for MN now
and he does miss that opportunity and
now it's his king that's under Fire King
D1 the move that we were talking about
Robert forces black white to give up
more material yeah this is just over you
can pick up the queen immediately and he
does it
and he resigns so go catch with another
win he is on fire today
just Unstoppable he's a favorite on
paper a big big favorite and he shows
why he lives up to it and big style
taking the match in each and every
segment with a dominating performance
and now with the white pieces and just
12 and a half minutes remaining for the
rest of the match there's no coming back
for it but for Emin it's just about
trying to get a couple of wins in if he
can as a silver lining
yeah I want to score a few important
wins you want to earn yourself a little
bit more cash and you just want to feel
better about how the match has gone
because it's been as one side as it gets
21-5 in guest's favor but look at how
combative the chess has been look at
this game here Tanya this Knight goes up
to F5 can black just play D4 we saw a
variation similar to this where black
had these pawns they seem to like these
lines
yeah very energetic play by both these
players they haven't backed down
Fearless chess regardless of the
scoreline we've seen by both Emin and
gagesh and a crazy position right now D4
played but the Knight isn't hanging so
he just takes this moment to get the
king to safety there's a pin along the
d-line and wow black ghost shark Castle
after having all these pawns which are
down the board all the weaknesses on the
king side I see the eval bar but Robert
this can get dangerous very quickly for
the black king yeah look at this move F3
trying to pry open the G file that you
told me was very important not to forget
about so I haven't and he puts F4 at the
moment trying to kick this Knight away
if the Knight goes to C6 the C4 Pawn
drops D3 the queen can move up to C3 and
C4 will still drop in the near future so
it's a very tricky position I'm starting
to like White's chances
tricky and it once again in the bullet
you obviously don't care about what the
eval Bar says but if you just look at
the position visually yes Black's got
these two pawns down the board but the
king feels so unsafe right now and one
by one the pawns are just falling you
can even pick up Bishop D3 right now
they are falling but what Black's trying
to do is take on e4 Play Bishop to F6
and speaking of unsafe Kings with a
bishop on F6 and the queen lined up on
the B file the B2 Pawn would be under
attack with checkmating threats so look
at black very solid all the pieces on
good squares and now the Queens are off
the board so opposite color Bishops does
that mean it's a draw
what's the pawn counter but it's six to
white and white has an extra Pawn but
look at those two F pawns doubled up
opposite color Bishop should be holding
but this is bullet who cares what the
objective evaluation is anything can
happen till the very end it's about
flagging your opponent it's about being
the one who makes the last mistake and
once again H3 coming up he's trying to
free up the king side trying to create
some play there it's far from over
I have to say I'm quite impressed by
googash's Bullet uh I didn't know that
he was this strong in Bliss rookie won a
problem King CT 2 protect so I think G3
will drop but clearly white is not worse
White's not was but I don't even think
White
really wants us to get A4 and create
another
side preempting that Emin gets the
Knight into the game picks up the F4
Pawn things are getting a bit crazy
Black's also Super Active right now
I'm starting to like black chances here
with B3 coming in
you might not be too happy where to move
the king
D2 Bishop takes B2 this group takes a
four so you can't steal that pawn just
yet
not just yet but it's a forever weakness
The Rook is coming to B1 you might have
to fall back with your knight to C3
well there has to be tactics tree Rook
G2 check trading off the Rooks that's
very helpful for that you've taken you
pick up the B2 Pawn you could have
picked up
the beat or maybe not yeah the Knight
was under attack just there but now the
wait B3 is gone so is a five
and why does an extra pawn and White's
the one who's pushing because black
snide is super far away from that A4
pawn and look at that move Bishop C2
keeping the bishop two squares ahead of
the Knight to control all the squares
from which the Knight can get to the
queen side yeah then I will have to take
a slower route and Knight A5 a C6 with
the King goes to C5 not kicks five now
because 97 check
and now Knight C8 is coming with A7
oh but you're a king E5 so you give up
this bishop for the pawn and that's what
king before what a move by the way just
bring the king up all the way forward to
B7
whoa and it's black in time with
queening and now you're gonna see Queen
at night versus queen this is getting
crazy white tries to bring the Knight
back and he does because Black's Bishop
cannot stop A7 he had a big Bishop F4
first so the Knight couldn't stop the
pawn and then have to impossible to find
a bullet ohanyon laughs you know he's
beside himself and gukesh you know he
returns the favor of both players they
seem to be in pretty good spirits
yeah they're having fun this is bullet
it's not it's far from uh anything that
it's a different format completely it's
about being entertained it's about
having fun playing fast and that's what
Eman is doing right now but okay is just
so strong and look at this with the
black piecesh employs the same idea that
he has been with white the H Pawn Harry
the H Pawn is on fire today we have a
caracon you know they say in the Queen's
game at all pawns no hope but when I
look at good cash player I see a lot of
Pawns and I also see a lot of hoe this
person you know he's one of the hopes of
Indian chess and Tanya you know as a
compatriot of his I mean you know how
much does India pay attention to to
matches like this because I know chess
base India they're always a covering and
commentating hello if you're watching or
you see this later hi everybody uh but
also I believe the media often picks up
on these matches and they cover them as
well
yeah absolutely it's a big deal for the
Indian chess fans as well as the Indian
Community these matches are big ones
we've seen nehal win it we've seen Arjun
win it and then go on to have breakout
those were the breakout performances and
then go on to shine on the big stage so
there's a lot of interest and I think
for India they're all hoping that gokish
does Win It Go on to play the speed
Chess Championship and I'm sure the fans
are super happy to see the way he's
handled his first match and look at that
a sacrifice on H3
what's going on here rookie it can you
just go Queen G no you can't go Queen G4
you have to pick up the Rook but then
you can go pick up the bishop on H3
dude throws in Bishop G2 first because
he was losing a piece and if you move
the Rook back suddenly this queen gets
into H3 and you might be in some trouble
so this was out of desperation rather
than something he desired to do but it's
going to be an extra piece for white for
a couple pawns now can a hanyan convert
that
to play Fast Robert this is bullet pick
up the bishop think later
look alive he's thinking about Rook E3
trying to defend that H3 square but it's
so risky to do that but maybe it was the
right way to go because we see the eval
bar dip down and after King G2 I don't
believe that Queen G4 can be anything so
he starts with a check on H3 same where
are you going with the King if King F1
is like H2
oof
and you've got to go Bishop E4 then
H2 Bishop E4 Queen takes E8 I feel like
black has legit chances there
it's looking really tricky starts with
queen E8 the queen falls back he wants
to go to Queen H5 and start creating
counter player of his own also keeping
an eye on the H Pawn
that was an essential Tempo it seems
because now the Queen's in H5 stopping
the H Pawn also threatening to the King
goes out to E7 that's where it's gonna
Escape through look at the time by the
way both players down to about six
seconds
well it's bullet it's bound to happen B5
white completely winning with an extra
piece but as long as that H3 Pawn is
alive gokish will try and fight this one
out
Queen E5 played while that A3 Pawn does
fall the queen comes into Activity The
King has to step up to defend the
Bishops
this doesn't look very easy the king is
getting checked around a bunch back oh
back to D4 it goes queen of five because
I should bring the queen there
good spot there but Queen F2 was a big
threat
and he goes Queen G1 so he doesn't want
the king to run away but uh Bishop takes
D6
what is happening F6 spawn oh
Bishop C3 and this should be Checkmate
this has to be checkmate yeah this is a
game that will not slip the grasp of
Ohanian he gets a win and tonight with
four minutes and 23 seconds left in the
entire match I think we'll get two more
games
I think we're in for two more bullet fun
here and of course the players are
taking this match very seriously but
with the big margin that gokish has for
Emin to make a comeback in the bullet is
not possible but it's been a big fight
still playing Dynamic energetic chess
and we might be in for another fun game
Bishop D3 develop both players playing
standard opening ideas right now black
wants to play B6 Bishop B7 but do you
have enough time to get that in
important question because look at
White's pieces on the D file there are
many of them there also staring towards
the black king side so you do need to be
careful if you're a minute he's not
moving
he's not moving 30 seconds on the clock
and wow that was a long tank in a bullet
game to pick up that Knight on C3
yeah too long because now go cash is
more time than he started with and oh
honey I'm down to 25 seconds himself
eight six what can think about starting
to line up the bishop and the queen
along the diagonal you can start with
Rook C1 the bishop falls back to B1 the
gokish with a different approach
centralizes the bishop The Rook will
land on C1
and it does and maybe Queen E2 here
yeah no white yeah like Bishop B1 sorry
I agree with you I say White's looking
good and Bishop B1 going to the diagonal
and trying to line them all up it looks
great with the bishop 1 C3 as well
I love it a lot of attacking
possibilities and of course up on the
clock again this
Bishop D4 you can't pick up the bishop
and E4 the queen is hanging and white is
threatening to trade on C6 destroying
black spawn structure Queen G4 would
threaten a mate on G7
yes how should you stop that maybe E5
not really the movie you want to play
but there's a lot of tension going on
between the pieces
E5 yeah it's such a commitment move
Robert so many weaknesses along the
light squares but it might be the choice
to go for instead he defends with the
bishop now the C6 spawn is weak and this
is one of those very pleasant positions
for white to play yeah you play without
any risk whatsoever if your opponent
plays perfectly they'll make a draw but
if he makes any sort of mistake pushes a
pawn too soon the pawns get weak and
maybe white can pick them off
Rook defends the C6 spawn and it's all
about can white find a breakthrough here
a very pleasant position but what's next
he stops any activity on the queen side
with that A3 move the bishop on D4
nicely placed it's being destabilized
now
but I like what Ohanian has done he's
taken control of the only open file in
the position doubling up on the d-line
yeah it looks good but if the Queens
come off the board suddenly white is
going to be very happy the A4 Pawn can
be best defended by the queen that's
situated on B5 but if these Queens come
off the board then there's gonna be a
problem on the A4 Square
two seconds for
average right now the problem is the
clock but look at it he's going for
white skiing he's trying to double up
and uh threaten some sacrifices on G3
and queen oh Queen needs to get up to D4
somehow that Queen presses forward
Black's King is in trouble
but black screen taking control of all
those Central squares also if black
trades the queens and the D3 Pawn fall
so Queen D4 is a possibility any end
game will be winning for white and I
think he missed that opportunity before
black got the bishop to C5 yeah Queen D4
is nice Queen takes D3 didn't work
because the G3 Pawn would have been
loose but instead whoa is King D1 Queen
B3 check Queen goes back to E6
borderline pre-moved
this Pawn on D3 is so strong
so strong it's coming to D2 as well the
only thing is that Black's King is
really weak and queen D4 is always in
the air never trade Queens here because
then white is completely winning but
Robert maybe it's too late maybe white
is anyway winning because the king picks
up the D3 Pawn
Queen takes F1 he puts the queen in a
hanging square and kukesh takes it
there's 18 seconds left which means we
get one final game Tanya I mean gukesh
he ran away with his match early and he
continues to score points
and look at that score line eight two H2
and a potential H2 coming up in the
bullet as well
what is this again the three minor
pieces for the queen this was really
good for black I thought but perhaps
Ohio looked at it a bit and so he's
happy to repeat the line although the
more I look at this position I don't see
how anyone could be happy to have the
white pieces in this one
continues to play fast as does MN but
it's too little too late the position
itself is imbalanced
once again the three minor pieces
against the queen as long as there are
no weaknesses around the king are often
the ones that are better and stronger
you just need to find your Harmony the
bishop on F5 can fall back to G6 to
defend that tender F7 spot
oh look at that there's Bishops are
under threat right now
how do you defend them
because if you go 97 white can actually
go Rook takes E7 Bishop E7 Queen F5 but
that might be the only move and then you
go Rook A4
yeah it does seem like white has a lot
of material right you've oh that's such
a good okay far on the board yeah you
could find by you could find my Google
Double exclam you take the Rook you get
background checkmated you don't take the
Rook you lose this bishop so great fine
Tanya that was really excellent spotted
yeah this is uh I'm so happy to see the
brilliancee spot proud of myself that
Rook A4 hitting that Rook taking
advantage of the back rank weakness I
think Bishop F7 was the only response in
the position Robert I'm afraid this
one's ending H2 as well
it looks like it black has a rook a
knight and a bishop for a queen and just
one Pawn so 10 points for white that
sounds like 11 for black with that
material and oh my goodness every piece
is defended and defending something this
is brilliant stuff from good cash
before coming in taking advantage of the
pin along this the C line but you've got
to be a little careful because that Rook
on C4 can become a Target along the
diagonal so don't rush it before he does
exactly that now Knight H5 Knight G3
ideas in the air
yeah this Rook on E5 defends the bishop
so there's no sacrifices and no threats
against it on E7 and plenty of time for
I would think of Rook C4 to eat a C6 and
then Rook to E6 let's just double my
Rooks
King G6 interesting choice there by
gokish walking into a check and G5 wait
that did he just hang the pawn
there's got to be before yeah and then
you go Rook F1 Bishop G1 Bishop F2
Bishop G3
oh you've got to stop that he
just
power play there
he resigned and they're starting a new
game but I don't think it's going to
count because the match clock has
elapsed completely gukesh is our winner
in the first Junior speed Chess
Championship quarterfinal
and with that dominating performance
gokish advances to the semi-finals it is
the end of the road for MN o'hanian he
was Brave today but just facing the
Monstrous gakesh who was so informed
taking it eight to in each of the
segments it's been and all out go case
show today
eight two eight two eight two so
yesterday the 0.9 finished for iterizaga
today 8-2 that's the number that you
need to remember 24-6 overall Tanya you
don't see matches this lopsided very
often
it is the magic numbers for the day
Robert and I think our smarter chess
prediction was 18 to 10 for gakesh and
this one he just takes it to a whole new
level and with that win gokish goes on
to the semi-finals he will be playing
against the winner of the next match
that's coming up and that's going to be
a big big fight and Rob it in my eyes
that's a closer match to call
oh it's impossible to pick a favorite
there because both of those players are
evenly matched in Blitz and bullet their
ratings are quite similar uh Christopher
you he is a chess composer he's won
awards for chess composition he's a
brilliant kid and so is pranav buddy you
know he's very popular on the chess
Broad Channel he did well in some Pro
chess league matches and he's been
playing in the just finished Asian
Continental Championship so he's very
active over the board I believe he got a
silver medal in the Asian Continental
blitz so he's had many successes to his
name that match is too close for me to
call
and this is our bracket we are done with
the first match of the quarterfinals of
the junior speed Chess Championship
cookies with a dominating performance
against Emin Ohanian there 24-6 and now
it's Christopher you the Tactical master
the masterful play in tactics by
Christopher you we're all aware of that
pranab will be facing that a very close
match no favorites in that one that's
coming up uh Robert is going to be an
exciting one as you mentioned too hard
to pick a favorite but if I had to put
you on a spot right now
and ask you to make a prediction what
would it be who's going through to the
semi-finals oh my goodness you know I do
this to people all the time so I I
appreciate you returning the favor I'm
gonna go with
we're all going to win because you know
chess is a beautiful game and we're all
learning and having a good time but I'm
gonna go with buddy pranav I just think
that he's very informed in all spheres
of Chess and so I'm gonna go with him
with the slightest of nods
wow and pranav we've seen him in the
protest league as well he's so strong in
these speeches formats Robert he loves
to play he loves to play these faster
formats and that's what he's up against
but he will be playing against
Christopher you and it's gonna be a big
big fight it's been such a fun day of
Chess and the action continues and I've
Loved chat keeping us updated with all
that's going on entitled Tuesday sharing
their thoughts on the match sending Good
Vibes to Emin on a very difficult day
Robin it's been like a bit of a
community that we've had going with the
chat here
yeah no the uh chat is awesome when they
decide to behave and I decide to pay
them some attention it's okay we had a
good day today I appreciate you but in
all seriousness we always appreciate
everybody tuning in watching the matches
learning having fun along the way it
makes it that much more fun for everyone
involved
and speaking of
activity Club this is the place to be
for all info on community tournaments
giveaways contests and other events plus
connect with the community and stay up
to date on the Chess World use the
command community in chat to get in on
all the action don't miss out on that
and don't miss out on the match that is
coming up as Christian Christopher you
takes on Prana we in the next
quarterfinal of this junior speed Chess
Championship Mike line and Amman
Hamilton will be calling all the action
it's a goodbye from Robert and myself
see you later chat
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you